START THAT THE HEARING TODAY.
WAITING FOR OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO SHOW UP BUT THE SHOW
GOES ON SO OF COURSE ISN'T
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER.
TWO ON EDUCATION FINANCE TODAY
WERE DISCUSSING THE CSU BUDGETS
THAT WE ALL KNOW OF THE GREAT
VALUE THE CSU.
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA I FORGOT MY
LITTLE CSU BUTTON BUT SEMI DESK
MAYBE SOME COULD BRING ERICA
SHOCK MY CSU PRIDE.
WE NOW SEE THAT CSU SYSTEM.
IS THE LARGEST -- PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM IN OUR NATION
ONE INTO IN PLACE IN CALIFORNIA
THE CSU GRADUATE AND EQUALLY
IMPRESSIVE OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS GET THEIR
DEGREE EACH YEAR BACHELOR'S
DEGREE EACH YEAR -- FROM THE CSU.
WE HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT RE
INVESTMENTS AND IN HIGHER AT THE
LAST FIVE YEARS BUT CAN YOU LOOK
AT WHERE WE WERE OUT IN THE CUTS
IN THE GREAT RISK RECESSION. FOR
JUST KIND OF GETTING BACK TO TO
WHERE WE WE SHOULD WE SHOULD BE
AND AND FRANKLY A LITTLE BIT
BELOW.
WE'RE STILL NOT DOING ENOUGH AS
FAR AS SERVING ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS EVERY YEAR THIRTY
THOUSAND QUALIFIED.
A CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL GRADS
APPLY TO THE CSU QUALIFIED
STUDENTS AND THE DENIED ACCESS
ONE ISSUE WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING ON GRADUATION RATES
STILL AREN'T GOOD ENOUGH SUPER
PROUD THE EFFORT THAT SOME SEE
ISSUES ARE DOING INCLUDING RIGHT
DOWN THE ROAD HERE AT SAKS STATE
AND WE'RE CONTINUING. TO WORK ON
THOSE ISSUES AND AND INVESTING
IN OUR IN OUR GRADUATION
INITIATIVE WORK AND THAT
CERTAINLY HELPS STUDENTS
GRADUATE -- IN FASTER CLIP WILL
LET WITH THE LAST -- DEBT LOAD
BUT ALSO FREES UP SPACE FOR MORE
CALIFORNIANS TO ENTER -- THE CSU
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS WE
TALKED ABOUT IN THE OVER THE
HEARING A FEW WEEKS AGO FOR YOU
SEE CSU INCOMMUNICADO IS.
IS A GOOD STARTING POINTS
PROBABLY THE BEST JANUARY BUDGET.
THERE WAS SEEN -- THEY BE EVER
NORMALLY HAVE THE INCREASES IN
THE MAY REVISED -- YOU KNOW
WE'RE NOT CERTAIN AS FAR AS HOW
MUCH FLEXIBILITY WE'RE GONNA
HAVE.
WHEN THE MAY REVISION COMES OUT
AS FAR AS REVENUES IN GENERAL
FUND BUT CERTAINLY ONE THING
THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO TO FOCUS
ON OUR TOP PRIORITY?
IS -- ENROLLMENT GROW AND MAKE
SURE WE EXPAND ACCESS FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS I KNOW THAT
SEE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO GROW BY --
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS NEXT
YEAR AND THE JANUARY BUDGET ONLY
HAS -- RESOURCES TO GROW BY
SEVEN THOUSAND SO THAT'S ONE OF
THE TOP ISSUES AGAIN WILL BE
LOOKING AT LOOK FOR TODAY'S
HEARING.
AND AND TALKING ABOUT HOW THE
CSU AND THE LEGISLATURE CAN
FOCUS ON OUR ON OUR JOINT
PRIORITY SO WITH THAT LET'S
BEGIN.
WITH BRING UP THE CSU DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THE LA OUT.
THE FIRST ISSUE WILL HERE
RELATED.
TO THE BUDGET AND ENROLLMENT.
OKAY BERMAN FINANCE PLEASE BEGIN.
REBECCA KIRK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
SIXTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING GENERAL FUND FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH OF 2% AT THE
CSU.
WHICH EQUATES TO APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTY THREE HUNDRED FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT RESIDENT STUDENTS.
THIS INVESTMENT AS PART OF OVER
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
NEW ON GOING GENERAL FUND
PROPOSED FOR THE CSU FOR VARIOUS
PRIORITIES AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
AS A CONDITION OF RECEIVING THIS
FUNDING THE ADMINISTRATION
EXPECTS TUITION TO REMAIN FLAT
IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY WHICH THE
CSU HAS INDICATED -- AGREEMENT
TO DO.
AND WE'VE ALSO INDICATED
EXPECTATION THAT ACCESS WILL
INCREASE.
AND ALSO THAT IT WILL BE THE
BEGINNING OF A CONVERSATION OR
DISCUSSION WITH THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES ON SHORT AND LONG TERM
OBJECTIVES.
AND EXPECTATIONS FOR THE SEGMENT.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OKAY THANK YOU LA OF POSTING
HOUSE IN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
LEGISLATURE WE HAD SEVERAL
FACTORS TO CONSIDER WHEN
DECIDING ON A LEVEL OF
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FUNDING TO
PROVIDE CSU.
VERSUS DEMOGRAPHICS -- THE
NUMBER OF HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
IN THE STATE IS PROJECTED TO
DECLINE SLIGHTLY.
THIS YEAR WHICH MEANS ALL OTHER
THINGS BEING EQUAL THE I.
ENROLLMENT DEMAND FOR FRESHMAN
SLOTS IN THE BUDGET YEAR WOULD
DECREASE ACCORDINGLY.
AS THE AGENDA NOTES THOUGH CSU
IS BEEN DRYING FROM BEYOND THE
STATE'S LONGSTANDING FRESHMAN
ELIGIBILITY POLICY WHICH IS
LIMITED FRESHMAN ADMISSION TO
THE TOP ONE THIRD OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
LEARNED THAT SEE IF YOU HAVE
BEEN DRYING FOR FROM JUST OVER
40% OF HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES.
AND UPDATED INFORMATION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SUGGEST THAT CSU IS
DRAWING FROM AN EVEN LARGER POOL
TODAY.
LIKELY DUE IN PART TO DRY BEYOND
THE TRADITIONAL ENROLLMENT POOL.
IN FALL TWENTY EIGHTEEN ABOUT
NINETEEN THOUSAND FRESHMAN
APPLICANTS PLUS ANOTHER TWELVE
THOUSAND TRANSFER APPLICANTS MET
CS USE MINIMUM SYSTEM WIDE
REQUIREMENTS BUT THEY WERE NOT
ACCEPTED AT ANY CAMPUS. TO WHICH
THEY APPLIED.
SO OF KNOWING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO PROVIDE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FUNDS TO
INCREASE LOTS AND REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF THOSE REJECTED
APPLICANTS KNOWN AS TONIGHT
ELIGIBLES.
NOW IF THE LEGISLATURE DID MAKE
THIS DECISION -- IT WOULD BE A
GOOD IDEA TO MAKE THAT CLEAR TO
CSU WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THE ROLE
IN THE GROWTH FUNDING IS A NOT
SO SEE IF YOU.
CAN FOCUS THE ENROLLMENT GROWTH
FUNDING ON PROGRAMS AND CAMPUSES
THAT HAVE EXPERIENCED A HIGH
AMOUNT OF A NET ENROLLMENT
DEMAND.
FINALLY ON ITS PAGES SIX AND
SEVEN OF YOUR AGENDA NOTE AND
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WILL
EXPLAIN THIS YEAR CSU IS
IMPLEMENTING A NEW REDIRECTION
POLICY FOR APPLICANTS WHO ARE
DENIED ADMISSION AT ALL THE
CAMPUSES -- TO WHICH THEY
APPLIED SO GOING FORWARD THE
LEGISLATURE WILL RUN AT WORK
WITH CSU TO MONITOR HOW MANY OF
THESE REDIRECTED APPLICATIONS IN
APPLICANTS AND UP AND ROLLING.
IN A CAMPUS WITH AVAILABLE
CAPACITY AND THEN ALSO LOOK AT
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THIS CREATES
ENROLLMENT PRESSURE ON CSU TO TO
FIND US TO FUND THESE
[inaudible]
THE STUDENTS.
THANK YOU HAPPEN ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SEE IF YOU.
I THANK YOU FOR DEDICATING THIS
ENTIRE.
BUDGET HEARING TO SEE SHE TODAY
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW WORDS
AT THE GET GO ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY -- BEFORE DELVING
INTO -- AT THE RUMINATION OTHER
ISSUES ON YOUR AGENDA TODAY.
MY NAME IS RYAN STORM ON THE
SYSTEM VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
BUDGET -- FOR THE OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR.
AND MANY OF THE ISSUES. TO BE
DISCUSSED TODAY ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT -- TO THE UNIVERSITY
AND WE HAVE HAD MANY SUCCESSES
IN THESE ISSUE AREAS BECAUSE OF
THE FUNDING YOU'VE PROVIDED THE
UNIVERSITY SO AND OUR ABILITY TO
EXECUTE WITH THOSE DOLLARS. FOR
EXAMPLE ARE FUNDED ENROLLMENT.
OUR OUR FUNDED NEW ENROLLMENT
HAS GROWN MORE THAN THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT STUDENTS
SINCE THE GREAT RECESSION.
AND THIS IS EQUIVALENT TO THIRTY
EIGHT THOUSAND MORE STUDENTS.
IN OUR TOTAL STUDENT ACCOUNT IS
NEARLY ONE HALF MILLION STUDENTS.
ALSO AS YOU ARE HERE -- WE ARE
EXCITED BY OUR SUCCESS
INCREASING GRADUATION RATES FOR
ALL SEE ISSUE STUDENTS WHILE
LIMITING OPPORTUNITY ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS -- THROUGH GRADUATION ISSUE
OF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO MAKE -- PROVE METS
AND ADDRESS SIGNIFICANT
DEFICIENCIES IN THE FACILITIES
AND UNDERLYING INFRASTRUCTURE OF
OUR TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES.
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S UP BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR THE C. ISSUE.
IT IS SIGNIFICANT THAT PROPOSAL
WILL HELP US KEEP PACE WITH OUR
OPERATING COST INCREASES
CONTINUE MOMENTUM IN IMPROVING
GRADUATION RATES.
IT WILL HELP US ACCOMMODATE A
GROWING DEMAND FOR ENROLLMENT.
IT ALLOWS THE POOR ALMOST TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
INTO THE NEEDS OF SEE ISSUE A
FACILITIES.
A REAL BRIEFLY I'LL MENTION THAT
YOU PROBABLY HAVE ALL SEEN THIS
BEFORE BUT I JUST PROVIDE YOU
HAND OUT THAT -- YOUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MEMBERSHIP AND STAFF
REALLY APPRECIATE WHICH SHOWS
THE CSU BUDGET REQUEST -- VERSUS
WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS PROVIDED
IN HIS REQUEST OBVIOUSLY THERE
IS A SIGNIFICANT FILLING UP OF
THAT BUCKET AND AND LIKE I SAID
WE ARE STILL VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO TO TO
THIS POINT.
WE ALSO STAND READY AS A C.
ISSUE TO SERVE ADDITIONAL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR'S
DECIDE TO FULLY FUND ARE ROAMING
GROWTH.
AND OUR GRADUATION IT SHOULD
HAVE BUDGET REQUESTS.
AND WE BELIEVE OUR GOOD
STEWARDSHIP INSTANT SUCCESSES
WARRANT THE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCHFROM MY
VANTAGE POINT BUT I'D LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO TALK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT ENROLLMENT --
TO MY CALL WITH. TO MY
COLLEAGUES.
GOOD MORNING.
I AM DOCTOR EVIL GROWN DIRECTOR
ROOMMATE MANAGEMENT SERVICES FOR
ACADEMIC AND STUDENT AFFAIRS AT
THE CSU CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DIRECT ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
TODAY.
AS THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN ACADEMIC YEAR BEGAN
OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS WERE
ROCKED AND ROLLED ACROSS THE
TWENTY THREE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES.
THAT NUMBER REPRESENTS THE FIFTY
YEAR OF RECORD STUDENT
ENROLLMENT IN THE CSU.
AND NEARLY THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND
MORE STUDENTS THAN JUST FIVE
YEARS AGO.
WELL THE CSU HAS BEEN LASER
FOCUSED ON IMPROVING DEGREE
COMPLETION AND REDUCING TIME TO
DEGREE.
AS WILL BE DISCUSSED FURTHER IN
THE NEXT PANEL WE HAVE ALSO
MAINTAINED EMPHASIS ON OUR
MISSION OF ACCESS.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT POINT FROM
WHICH TO START OUR DISCUSSIONS
TODAY.
BECAUSE WALL IN ROMAN IS OFTEN
CONSIDERED ONLY IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE ADMISSION OF NEW STUDENTS.
THE MORE CRITICAL ELEMENT OF
ENROLLMENT MANAGEMENT IS SERVING
CONTINUING STUDENTS.
AS FOR THE CSU THEY COMPRISE
APPROXIMATELY 70% OF OUR
ENROLLMENT.
THIS DELICATE BALANCING ACT OF
ENROLLMENT IS IMPERATIVE TO
MAINTAINING NOT ONLY ACCESS TO
THE CSU BUT AUTHENTIC ACCESS.
WE'RE ALL STUDENTS BOTH
CONTINUING AND NEW HAVE THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND EARN A HIGH
QUALITY DEGREE IN A TIMELY
MANNER. FOR FALL TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN OVER THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS APPLIED FOR ADMISSION
TO THE CSU AS A FRESHMAN
TRANSFER STUDENT.
AND 77% WERE ADMITTED TO THE CSU.
ULTIMATELY OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN THOUSAND AND THOSE
STUDENTS ENROLLED LAST FALL A
RECORD NEW STUDENT ENROLLMENT
AND OVER SEVENTEEN THOUSAND MORE
STUDENTS FOR THE FALL TERM IN
JUST SIX YEARS AGO.
I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
TREMENDOUS GROWTH OF THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
PATHWAY WHICH WAS CREATED BY
SENATE BILL SB FOURTEEN FORTY IN.
TWO THOUSAND TEN IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN ALMOST TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND NEW TRANSFER
STUDENTS FROM CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ARRIVED AT THE CSU WITH AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
THAT'S ABOUT ONE THIRD OF OUR
ENTERING TRANSFER STUDENT
POPULATION.
THIS NUMBER IS A 60% INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF NEW TRANSFERS WHO
AREN'T IN AT T. PRIOR TO
TRANSFER COMPARED 220-001-42000.
FIFTEEN THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
TREND BECAUSE TRANSFER STUDENTS
WHO HAVE EARNED IN AT T. AND FOR
THE CSU BETTER PREPARED.
AND HAVING COMPLETED SPECIFIC
COURSE WORK AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THAT SATISFIES AT LEAST
HALF OF THEIR CSU DEGREE
REQUIREMENTS.
AT THE SAME TIME WE SEE THESE
TRANSIT IMPROVEMENTS FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS WE ARE
EXPERIENCING IMPROVED OUTCOMES
FOR THOSE STUDENTS EXITING HIGH
SCHOOL WHO SEEK TO ATTEND
COLLEGE AFTER GRADUATION.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION REFER.
REPORTS THAT ALMOST 50% OF LAST
YEAR'S PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES COMPLETED THE SET UP
CSU AND YOU SEE COLLEGE
PREPARATORY COURSES KNOWN AS A
THREE G. COMPARED 234% A DECADE
AGO.
EACH YEAR WE CONTINUE TO SEE
MORE BETTER PREPARES STUDENTS
SEEKING HIGH QUALITY AFFORDABLE
CSU DEGREE.
IN FACT OVER SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND MORE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS APPLIED FOR FALL
ADMISSION LAST YEAR THAN IN FALL.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN AS A
REFERENCE EARLIER PLANNING FOR
AND MANAGING ENROLLMENT REQUIRES
CLOSE ATTENTION NOT ONLY TO NEW
AND FUTURE STUDENTS BUT AS
IMPORTANTLY ATTENTION TO THE
ENROLLMENT DEMAND AND CAPACITY
FOR CONTINUING STIRRED.
ALL TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES USE A
VARIETY OF STRATEGIES TO
MAXIMIZE THE FINITE AND ROAMING
CAPACITY THAT EXIST ON A CAMPUS.
FOR EXAMPLE CAMPUS AS REGULAR
CREATE AND REFINED DEGREE ROAD
MAPS. FOR FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER
STUDENTS THESE ROAD MAPS ALLOW
STUDENTS AND COUNSELORS TO VIEW
AND UPDATE A SEMESTER BY
SEMESTER PLAN.
CAMPUSES SUBSEQUENTLY YOU USE
THIS DATA TO PLAN THE CLASS
SCHEDULE AND TO PROVIDE THE
COURSE IS NEEDED BASED ON
STUDENT DEGREE REQUIREMENTS
PROVIDING OPTIMAL PASS FOR
GRADUATION AND A TOOL.
FOR EFFICIENCY EFFICIENTLY
MANAGING ENROLLMENT.
STUDENT ROAD MAP DATA THE NUMBER
OF MAJORS PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS
AND PRIOR YEAR ENROLLMENT
PATTERNS ARE USED TO
CONTINUOUSLY ANALYZE COURSE
DEMAND.
CAMPUSES PAID PARTICULAR
ATTENTION TO HIGH DEMAND COURSES
PRIORITIZING CLASSROOM
SCHEDULING IN FACULTY
ASSIGNMENTS FOR THESE COURSES.
WITH SUPPORT FROM THE CSU
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE CAMPUSES ARE
PROVIDING TRAINING AND RESOURCES
TO FACULTY TO RE DESIGN COURSES
TO OPTIMIZE THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY.
THIS INCLUDES MOVING COURSES
FULLY ONLINE OR TO HIGH BRED
FORMATS A MIX OF ONLINE AND IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION.
IT ALSO INCLUDES THE USE OF
VIRTUAL LABS ENGAGING STUDENTS
IN EXPERIMENTS AND SIMULATIONS
ARE INNOVATIVE ONLINE
TECHNOLOGIES.
FINALLY CAMPUSES ARE INCREASING
ADVISING RESOURCES AND
TECHNOLOGIES THAT SUPPORT
STUDENTS TO THEIR GRADUATION
GOALS AND HELP CAMPUSES MANAGE
ENROLLMENT.
ALL CAMPUSES USE A COMBINATION
OF THE A FOUR MENTIONED
STRATEGIES TO MAXIMIZE STUDENT
ACCESS TO COURSES AND SUPPORT.
REGARDLESS WHETHER OR NOT THE
CAMPUS IS IMPACTED.
HOWEVER ONCE THE STRATEGIES ARE
NO LONGER SUFFICIENT ON THEIR
OWN FOR MANAGING ENROLLMENT I
CAMPUS MAY REQUEST TO DECLARE
IMPACTION TO BETTER CONTROL THE
ENROLLMENT OF NEW STUDENTS.
SHORTLY THE CSU WILL BEGIN THE
REDIRECTION A FIRST TIME
FRESHMAN ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER AND UPPER DIVISION
TRANSFER APPLICANTS.
WHO MEET CSU MINIMUM ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS AND WE'RE NOT
ADMITTED TO ANY CSU CAMPUS THEY
APPLIED FOR FALL?
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN APPLICANTS
WILL BE ABLE TO SELECT A FIRST
AND SECOND CHOICE CAMPUS TO HAVE
THEIR APPLICATION RE DIRECTED.
ANY APPLICANT THAT DOES NOT
RESPOND WILL ALSO BE REDIRECTED
TO A CAMPUS THAT STILL HAS
CAPACITY TO ENSURE ALL CSU
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS HAVE A SPOT
AT THE CSU IF THEY WANT TO
ATTEND.
IN CLOSING INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES
AND THE CSU SYSTEM ARE CAREFULLY
BALANCING AND ROMAN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PART
CONTINUING STUDENTS SEEKING TO
MAKE TIMELY PROGRESS TOWARDS
THEIR DEGREE WITH THE GROWING
PERSPECTIVE.
STUDENT POPULATION FROM
CALIFORNIA'S HIGH SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHICH IS
LARGER.
BETTER PREPARED AND MORE DIVERSE.
CAMPUSES MUST CAREFULLY CONSIDER
AND EVALUATE THEIR CAPACITY IN
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE AUTHENTIC
ACCESS TO CONTINUING AND NEW
STUDENTS.
WITH OVER FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS 94% OF
WHICH ARE FROM CALIFORNIA THE
CSU EDUCATES THE MOST ETHNICALLY
ECONOMICALLY AN ACADEMICALLY
DIVERSE UNIVERSITY STUDENT BODY
AND THE NATION.
STUDENTS FAMILIES AND SCHOOLS
HAVE ALL TAKEN THE RIGHT STEPS
TO PREPARE FOR COLLEGE BUT TO
MEET THE DEMAND FROM INCREASING
NUMBERS OF STUDENTS AND AS
IMPORTANTLY ME CALIFORNIA'S
NEEDS FOR AN EDUCATED WORKFORCE
TO REMAIN COMPETITIVE IN THE US
AND GLOBALLY.
WE WILL NEED RESOURCES TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN OFFER THEM A PLACE
THAT THE CSU.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
OF COUPLE HELLO BUT MISTER
DONALD GET READY. FOR THIS
QUESTIONS ALL START OUT WITH THE
REDIRECTION.
ISSUE AYE AYE I THINK THAT'S A
GOOD POLICY AND I KNOW WE WE
PURSUED.
THIS THE LAST COUPLE YEARS.
AND I YOU'RE STARTING RIGHT NOW
SO IT'S HARD TO TELL HOW IT'S
GOING TO PLAY OUT.
AND OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE SON
COVETED CAMPUSES OF THE TWENTY
THREE SEE ISSUES WITH WE GET A
LOT OF APPLICATIONS FOR THEIR
IMPACTED.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS SAN DIEGO
LONG BEACH NICK THE CAL POLY'S
ARE ARE ARE SOME OF THE TOP ONES --
HOW REALISTIC YOU THINK THAT IT
WILL BE WHERE PEOPLE WILL WILL --
APPLY TO THESE CAMPUSES AND GET
REDIRECTED NOT TO DIMINISH.
THE OTHER ONE'S OWN IT DISPARAGE
BAKERSFIELD HOW ISLANDS
DOMINGUEZ HILLS HUMBLE SAN
FRANCISCO STANISLAUS -- BUT WHAT
WHAT WHAT DO YOU WHAT WHAT WOULD
BE PROJECT -- WHAT WILL HAPPEN
HERE?
AS THIS PLAYS OUT.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO PREDICT ANY
TYPE OF NUMBERS AT THIS POINT
SINCE THIS IS REALLY THE FIRST
YEAR THAT WE WILL BE RE RE
DIRECTING FIRST TIME FRESHMEN
AND UPPER DIVISION TRANSFERS AS
YOU KNOW PREVIOUSLY.
WE ONLY REDIRECTED ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS --
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
STUDENTS HAVE NOT REALLY TAKEN
ADVANTAGE EVERY DIRECTION SO WE
DO THANK THE NUMBER WILL BE
HIGHER.
BUT WE CAN'T REALLY PREDICT AT
THIS POINT IN TIME [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND THEN MY QUESTION FOR THE LA --
YOU MENTION THAT THAT THE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIANS IN
SCHOOL AGE IS GOING DOWN CORRECT
WE SEE THAT A K..
TWELVE POPULATION.
BUT BUT ISN'T THE THE FLIP SIDE
THAT WE HAVE MORE STUDENTS WHO
ARE EVEN OTHER FEWER ACTUALLY
HIGH SCHOOL.
GRADUATES THEY'RE MORE GRADUATES
WHO ARE.
TAKING THEIR A THREE G. COURSES
AND ARE READY FOR COLLEGE
HIMSELF DOESN'T THAT KIND OF
EQUAL OUT ARE POTENTIALLY --
SHOW THAT THERE'S MORE AND MORE
OF A DEMAND FOR YES THAT'S
HIGHER AT THAT'S CORRECT.
DECADE AGO OR SO IS ABOUT 34% OF
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES HAD
COMPLETED THEIR A THREE JEEZ.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN WE LEARNED LAST YEAR THE
NUMBER HAD GONE UP THE
PERCENTAGE YOU GOT UP TO ABOUT
41% OF HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES OF
SKEWS THE 43% OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADS.
HAD COMPLETED THREE THREE JEEZ
OF THAT. 81% -- HAD.
WE BEEN QUALIFIED TO GO TO CSU
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A CERTAIN GPA
OR SAT SCORES THEY NEEDED.
AND BETA WE LOOKED AT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
WHICH I MENTIONED MY REMARKS
INDICATES THAT THAT PERCENTAGE
IS GONE UP SO IT'S 41%.
IN ONE YEAR 43% ANOTHER 45% AND
OTHER YEAR SO THAT'S CORRECT AND
LEGISLATURE JUST AS A NO AT THIS
POINT IF THAT 45% IS GOING TO
KEEP GOING UP FORTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE FIFTY ONE IF IT'S PEAK TO
IT'S IT'S NOT CLEAR BUT THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY TRUE IS THAT.
YOU'VE HAD A AN INCREASE IN THE
PERCENTAGE OF HIGH SCHOOL GRADS
THAT ARE COMPLETING THE RATE TO
JEEZ IN OUR IN OUR MEETING SEE
ISSUES -- ELIGIBLE REQUIREMENTS.
AND THEN IF THE STUDENTS --
EXCEPT THE REDIRECTION.
DO WE ANTICIPATE IF THEY ALL
ACCEPTED WE ANTICIPATE.
THERE WOULD HAVE ENOUGH MONEY IN
THE BUDGET TO COVER THAT WITH.
ENROLLMENT FUNDING WE'RE GIVING
YOU OR HAVE TO COME BACK THE
NEXT YEAR TO SORT THAT OUT --
FROM A BUDGETARY PERSPECTIVE WE
WOULD NOT HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO
TO FIND EVERY SINGLE STUDENT.
I KEEP IN MIND THOUGH THAT NOT
EVERYONE WHO APPLIES TO A C.
ISSUE ENDS UP -- WANTING TO GO
TO A C. ISSUE RIGHT THERE OTHER
THE OTHER COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE AND IN
THE COUNTRY -- BUT WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO A RIGHT NOW WHAT YOU
HAVE IN THE BUDGET SO FAR IS
ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS THAT WOULD
BE FUNDED UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL -- SO THERE'S MONEY
THERE THAT WE COULD USE TO
ABSORB INITIAL ENROLLMENT THE
OTHER PIECES THAT THERE SOME ONE
TIME FUNDING IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET -- THAT WE HAVE INTENSELY
HELD BACK KNOWING FULL WELL THAT
THIS RE DIRECTION POLICY WAS
GOING -- TO POTENTIALLY LAND
STUDENTS AT OTHER CAMPUSES ARE
PLAN GOING FORWARD IS TO
ALLOCATE THAT FUNDING TO THOSE
CAMPUSES IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THAT.
FUNDING GAP IF WE HAVE -- S.
TSUNAMIS SO TO SPEAK OF OF NEW
STUDENTS ENROLLING IN THE C.
ISSUES SO I THINK WE'RE GONNA BE
SOMEWHAT ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT
BUT IF IT WERE EVERYBODY WANTING
IN.
I THINK WE WOULD NOT HAVE ENOUGH
FUNDING IN ORDER COVERED ALL
OKAY.
AND BACK TO THE TO THE ISSUE TO
TO USE THE ISSUE AS FAR AS
SERVING.
ALL THE STUDENTS THAT -- ARE
APPLYING.
AT THE DE THE REQUESTED YOU.
HAVE THAT YOU SAY IS A HUNDRED
EIGHT MILLION.
THAT THAT THAT WOULD BE TO SERVE
ALL THE THIRTY THOUSAND THAT ARE.
DENIED EVERY YEAR IT'S CLOSER TO
TO THAT NO IT'S EQUIVALENT TO
ABOUT EIGHTEEN THOUSAND WRECKED.
AND THEN SO THE DIFFERENCE HERE
BETWEEN.
WHAT IT IN COURT IN YOUR CHART
IS THE IS THE ROUGHLY?
WHAT FORTY SIX MILLION RIGHT?
YEAH THE WHAT THAT THAT THE ONE
THING THAT WE DON'T WE HAVEN'T
CAPTURED ON THAT WHICH WOULD
MAKE IT A BIT MORE CONFUSING IS
THAT WE HAVE WE WITH NEW IN ROME
THAT COMES ADDITIONAL TUITION
REVENUE RIGHT YOU HAVE A MORE
STUDENTS SO.
THERE IS THAT PIECE OF IT THAT
FACTORS AND I GUESS A SIMPLE
QUESTION IS THAT IF WE DID WANT
TO DO.
THE EIGHTEEN THOUSAND WHICH WE
DO WORK.
THERE IS A NUMBER THAT YOU SAID
IT WOULD COST US NINETY MILLION
AND THEN THAT'S WHEN YOUR CHART
SAYS WOULD ONLY COST US. FORTY
SIX MILLION SO WHAT'S THE NUMBER
RIGHT IT'S NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS WHAT WHAT I'M WHAT I'M
NOT DEPICTING ON THAT SLIDE
THERE IS THE TUITION REVENUE
THAT HELPS BALANCE THE ENTIRE
PLAN THERE SO IT'S NOT A IT'S
NOT A PERFECT GRAPHIC RIGHT
THERE BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT.
THE STATE WOULD HAVE TO
CONTRIBUTE ABOUT NINETY NINE
ALMOST NINETY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO GET 25% ON TOP OF
THAT ON TOP OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED AMOUNT YEAH.
AND THEN -- I THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT'S VERY UNCOMFORTABLE TO
TALK ABOUT THAT STUDENT FEES AND
WE WANT TO KEEP THEM.
AS LOW AS POSSIBLE.
BUT THERE IS A DOWNSIDE TO THAT.
SO AT AT CSU THE MAJORITY OF
YOUR STUDENTS ARE EITHER ON CAL
GRANT OR OTHER OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT PAY NO TUITION AND WHAT'S
THE NUMBER AGAIN THAT PERCENTAGE
ROUGHLY.
I THINK GENERALLY SPEAKING IT'S
ABOUT 60% OF OUR STUDENTS SO60%
HAVE A SUGG AT THE STATE
UNIVERSITY GRANT OR A CAL GRANT
OR YEAH MEANS YEAH.
YES SO OF COURSE WE WOULD LIKE
TO PUT MORE MONEY IN THE BUDGET
IN -- IN MAY.
HOPING THAT THE TAX RECEIPTS GO
UP AND RIGHT NOW THE ALLEY --
SAYING THAT IT'S NOT LOOKING
THAT.
THAT FAVORABLE -- SO THAT THAT
THAT THE DOWNSIDES WE MAKE THAT
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL MONEY TO
FOCUS ON FULL TIME FACULTY WHICH
ARE GOING TO HEAR -- OTHER
PRIORITIES LIKE ENROLLMENTS --
PROJECT REBOUND IDEA OR OTHER
ISSUES THAT WE THINK ARE
PRIORITIES -- IN THE IN THIS
BUDGET SO THAT THE STUDENT FEE
ISSUE IS INTERESTING BECAUSE IF
YOU INCREASE STUDENT FEES BY 4%.
60% YOUR STUDENTS PAY NO
ADDITIONAL -- MONEY AND THEN --
YOU KNOW PEOPLE ON THE UPPER
INCOME OF COURSE POTENTIALLY
COULD COULD PAY FROM AROUND%
SEATED IS THE REALLY THE SQUEEZE
ON BY FOLKS IN THE MIDDLE.
BUT THE FLIP SIDE IS THAT IS BY
NOT.
DOING THAT THEN THAT'S ROUGHLY.
YOU KNOW FIFTY OR SO MILLION THE
YOU DON'T HAVE. TO TO FOCUS ON
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVES OR
ISN'T THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
STUDENT ENROLLMENT SO.
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST SOMETHING
THAT -- WE HAVE TO REALIZE THAT
THERE'S A CONSEQUENCE OF THAT.
SO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER JENNER MISTER O'DONNELL.
OKAY SO WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE
OPEN AND REVISITED AFTER WE HERE
WHAT'S IN THE MAY REVISION AS
FAR AS REVENUE.
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO THE CSU GRADUATION ISSUE.
TO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT CONTINUED PROGRESS FOR
THE CS USE GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AS OUTLINED
IN THE AGENDA THE CSU IS MADE
CONSIDERABLE PROGRESS TOWARD THE
GOALS OF THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE WHICH WAS ADOPTED BY
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INVESTMENT WILL AID THE CSU AND
CONTINUING TO IMPROVE TIME
GRADUATION. FOR BOTH FRESHMEN
AND TRANSFER STUDENTS AS WELL AS
DECREASING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY LA OF HAS YOUR AGENDA NOTES
ON PAGE EIGHT CSU CURRENTLY
DESIGNATES A HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING.
RESOURCES FOR THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE.
AND THEY GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WOULD INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
BASS FUNNY NON GOING FUNDING FOR
THE GRAD INITIATIVE TO TWO
HUNDRED FORTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
CSU CONTINUES TO IMPROVE
GRADUATION RATES FOR BOTH FIRST
TIME FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER
STUDENTS.
GAPS IN GRADUATION RATES AMONG
CERTAIN RACIAL ETHNIC GROUPS
HAVE NARROWED ALBEIT SLIGHTLY
YOU CAN SEE THAT THE TABLE ON
PAGE.
EIGHT IN ADDITION DATA INDICATES
THAT STUDENTS ARE GRADUATING
WITH FEWER ACCESS UNITS WHICH
RESULTS IN LOWER COST TO THEM
AND THE STATE.
AND ALSO FREES UP COURSE SEATS
FOR OTHER STUDENTS.
SO OVERALL CSU IS SHOWING
IMPROVEMENT AND A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT AREAS PERTAINING TO
STUDENT PERFORMANCE AND IF THE
LEGISLATURE CHOOSES TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE GOING FORWARD.
WE RECOMMENDED A LINK FUNDING
FOR THE INITIATIVE TO AN
EXPECTATION THE CSU CONTINUE TO
MAKE PROGRESS ON KEY STUDENT
OUTCOMES INCLUDING IMPROVING
GRADUATION RATES.
NARROWING ACHIEVING GAPS AND
REDUCING EXCESS UNITS.
AND ONE WAY CSU COULD CREATE A
BETTER INCENTIVE FOR STUDENTS TO
AVOID EXCESS UNIT ACCUMULATION.
AND MAXIMIZE AID FOR OTHER
STUDENTS WOULD BE TO MODIFY A
POLICY ON CS USE INSTITUTIONAL
GRANT AWARD WHICH YEAH WE JUST
MENTION IS THE STATE UNIVERSITY
GRANT OR SUB.
CURRENTLY STUDENTS CAN RECEIVE A
STUDENT NUMBER CITY GRANT FOR UP
TO A HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEMESTER
UNITS WHICH IS A FULL YEAR'S
WORTH OF UNITS.
BEYOND WHAT IS TYPICALLY
REQUIRED FOR A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
BY CONTRAST STATE LAW LIMITS CAL
GRANTS FOR FOUR YEARS OF FULL
TIME IN.
ATTENDANCE OR THE EQUIVALENT
WHICH IS JUST A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY UNITS.
ANOTHER WAY FOR CSU TO FURTHER
REDUCE TEXAS UNITS WOULD BE TO
LIMIT THE NUMBER OF TIMES A
STUDENT CAN REPEAT.
THE SAME COURSE FOR A BETTER
GRADE.
MOST CAMPUSES ALLOW STUDENTS TO
TAKE THE SAME COURSE FOR UP TO
THREE TIMES.
AND STUDENTS TYPICALLY ALLOWED
TO REPEAT UP TO TWENTY EIGHT
UNITS OF COURSE WORK IN THIS WAY.
SO WE RECOMMENDED NACHMAN OF A
SYSTEM WIDE POLICY THAT LIMITS
STUDENTS TO TAKING THE SAME
COURSE FOR BETTER GRAY TWO TIMES
WHICH IS ALREADY THE POLICY ON A
NUMBER OF CSU CAMPUSES.
ARE GIVEN AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE CURRENTLY DOES NOT
COLLECT DATA ON UNITS
ACCUMULATED DUE TO COURSE
REPETITION THE LEGISLATURE COULD
REQUIRE SEE ISSUE TO REPORT THE
STATE AS PART OF A ANNUAL
PERFORMANCE REPORT THAT THEY
SUBMIT IN MARCH.
THANK YOU.
FOR THANK YOU CSU.
GOOD MORNING I'M JAMES MINOR
SYSTEM VICE CHANCELLOR AND
SENIOR STRATEGIST IN THE C.
ISSUE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE -- I
WANT TO MAKE A JUST A FEW
MENTIONS BY WAY OF UPDATE ON THE
GRADUATION ISSUE THANK YOU FOR
FOR HAVING US HERE THIS MORNING.
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW THIS IS --
QUITE AN AMBITIOUS AGENDA AND
INITIATIVE FOR THE C. ISSUE.
WHICH ENDEAVORS NOT ONLY TO BE
THE LARGEST AND MOST DIVERSE FOR
YOUR SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY BUT
THE FIRST AND BEST.
IN TERMS OF PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
HIGH QUALITY DEGREE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DIVERSE
STUDENTS -- A FEW YEARS AGO WHEN
WE STARTED THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE THE SYSTEM WHY FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION RATE WITH 19% --
NO QUESTION HERE THAT SOME OF
OUR CAMPUSES HAS SINGLE DIGIT
FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATES.
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE REALLY
FOCUSED OUR UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
AND JUST A COUPLE OF YEARS LATER
AS PAUL MENTIONED -- THE
GRADUATION RATES IN VIRTUALLY
EVERY CATEGORY.
ARE REPRESENTING ALL TIME HIGHS
FOR THE C. ISSUE.
THE FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE
HAS GONE FROM 19% 225%.
AND A SIX YEAR GRADUATION RATE
HAS GONE FROM 57% 261% WHICH IS
ABOVE THE NATIONAL AVERAGE FOR
LIKE INSTITUTIONS FOR FOUR YEAR
COMPREHENSIVE -- PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS WHICH IS PRETTY
REMARKABLE FOR SYSTEM.
AGAIN EACH OF THESE CATEGORIES
REPRESENT AN ALL TIME HIGH FOR
THE C. ISSUE JUST LAST YEAR'S
YOU HEARD APRIL MENTIONED IN THE
PREVIOUS SESSION.
THE C. ISSUE AWARDED A HUNDRED
AND FIVE BACCALAUREATE DEGREES
WHICH IS ALSO A AND AN ALL TIME
HIGH BUT BUT LET ME JUST PUT A
FINER POINT ON THAT.
THIS IS SIX THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
DEGREES OVER AND BEYOND WHAT THE
C. ISSUE PRODUCED IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR. THIRTEEN THOUSAND
MORE BACHELOR'S DEGREES THEN THE
CSU PRODUCE JUST TWO YEARS AGO --
THE SECOND THING THAT I WOULD
JUST MENTION IS THE FUNDING FOR
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
IN THE AMOUNT OF SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION AND REOCCURRING FUNDS IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS.
HAS WERE ALLOW THE C. ISSUE TO
DO THINGS THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO BY WAY
OF HIRE AN ADDITIONAL FACULTY --
ADICIONAL TENURE TRACK FACULTY
ADDITIONAL ADVISORS --
INVESTMENTS AND DATA CAPACITY
AND DATA INFRASTRUCTURE ON OUR
CAMPUSES WHICH HAS MADE A
REMARKABLE DIFFERENCE.
ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT -- BY
WAY OF A SORT OF AGGRESSIVE
POLICY CHANGES THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE MOST OF YOU OF HAVE HAVE --
LEARNED ABOUT THE DRAMATIC
DEVELOPMENT -- EDUCATION REFORM
THAT TOOK PLACE LAST YEAR.
I'M JUST JUST ONE MENTION IN
TERMS OF WHAT THAT IS MEANT --
EVERY YEAR THE C. ISSUE
PREVIOUSLY AND ROLLED ROUGHLY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
STUDENTS THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
ASSIGNED TO A DEVELOPMENTAL
EDUCATION COURSE.
OUT LAST YEAR THAT POLICY CHANGE.
THIS FALL -- THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS -- WHO OTHERWISE WOULD
HAVE BEEN RELEGATED TO A
DEVELOPMENTAL EDUCATION COURSE --
THE NUMBER OF THOSE STUDENTS
THAT ARE PASSING A LOWER
DIVISION MATH COURSE IN THEIR
FIRST TERM IS INCREASED EIGHT
FALL -- AGAIN WHICH IS PRETTY
REMARKABLE AGAIN WE'RE HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT I
WANT TO PUT THIS IN CONTEXT --
YOU LOOK AT ANY OTHER STATE --
AND JUST THE SCALE OF THE SEA
ISSUE THIS WITHOUT QUESTION HAS
BEEN THE LARGEST AND MOST
PROGRESSIVE DEVELOPMENTAL
EDUCATION REFORM IN THE COUNTRY --
THE LAST THING I'LL SAY JUST BY
WAY OF THE FUNDING OF ONE WE
ESTABLISH THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE GOALS WE LOOKED AT
PEER INSTITUTIONS WE ASSIGNED.
EACH OF OUR TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES A SET OF PEER
INSTITUTIONS TO ESTABLISH THE
GRADUATION RATE TARGETS.
WHAT WE LEARNED IN DOING THAT --
IS THAT ON AVERAGE THE PEER
INSTITUTIONS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WERE SPEND ROUGHLY A THOUSAND
MORE DOLLARS PER PUPIL.
RIGHT THEN THE SEA ISSUE -- AND
IN MOST CASES THE NATIONAL
DARLING IN THE IN IN THE COUNTRY
IS GEORGIA STATE -- BUT IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA -- WHERE AN IN STATE
STUDENTS GOING TO PAY TWICE AS
MUCH AS A AS A CALIFORNIAN WOULD
PAY?
AND WE NOW HAVE A NUMBER C.
ISSUE CAMPUSES THAT ARE
OUTPERFORMING GEORGIA STATE.
AT HALF THE COST OF WHICH IS
PRETTY REMARKABLE A SOUL OUR
REQUEST FOR THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
AND LARGE PART IS TO SUSTAIN THE
MOMENTUM THAT WE HAVE SEEN OVER
THE LAST -- TWO YEARS I THINK --
IT WILL SEND A VERY STRONG
SIGNAL -- THAT IF THE STATE.
THE SIZE TEN BASS LAST THEN THAT
IN THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE OUR
OUR INTENT IS TO KEEP OUR FOOT.
ON THE GAS IF YOU WILL AND AND
THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WILL ALLOW US TO DO THAT.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
QUESTION.
I WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE THE
DIFFERENTIAL IN SOME OF THE
CAMPUSES NEEDS OF OF COURSE ON A
BRAG ABOUT SEX DATING WE HAD
THEIR GRADUATIONS ARE.
LAST YEAR AT THIS PANEL.
AND IT'S JUST OFF THE CHARTS AS
FAR AS WHAT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
TO DO HERE AND MY UNDERSTANDING
IS IS SIMPLE.
EXPECTATIONS FROM THE GET GO.
THEY BRING THE STUDENTS AND WHEN
THEY FIRST AND ROLAND AND SHOW
THEM.
HEY IF YOU TAKE TWELVE UNITS A
YEAR VERSUS FIFTEEN THIS IS HOW
MUCH WILL MEAN AT THE END AS FAR
AS HOW MUCH DEBT YOU HAVE AND IN
ANOTHER YEAR.
OF IN SCHOOL IS A PARS EARNING
YOUR CREEK RUNNING EARNING MONEY
IN YOUR IN YOUR FUTURE CAREER.
SO WHY IS IT SO COMPLICATED
WIRED SOME OF THESE CAMPUSES.
STEPPING UP LIKE TAXED STATES.
TO WHAT YOU KNOW I THINK ALL OF
OUR CAMPUSES ARE.
EMPLOYING ACTIVITY UNIQUE TO
THEIR PARTICULAR CAMPUS AND THE
STUDENT POPULATION -- WE HAVE
TRIED TO GIVE CAMPUSES
SUFFICIENT AUTONOMY AND LEVERAGE
TO DO WHAT THEY BELIEVE IS BEST
FOR THEIR STUDENTS THEMSELVES
TAX STATUS MEMBER MARKETABLE --
BUT I CAN TELL YOU NOW THAT
SIMPLY EMPLOYING THOSE
STRATEGIES ON DIFFERENT CAMPUSES
YOU HAVE.
FAIRLY DIFFERENT OUTCOMES SO I
THINK YOU SEE A RANGE OF
ACTIVITY -- AND I THINK ALL OF
OUR CAMPUS IS A SAFE TO SAY ARE
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION SO
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THAT OUR
CHANCELLOR IS BEEN VERY CLEAR WE
WANT TO BE.
EXCEPTIONALLY CLEAR ON THE GOAL --
AND GIVE OUR CAMPUS PRESIDENTS
THE LATITUDE TO IT -- TOO EMPLOY
THAT STRATEGY IS A THINKER BASS
FOR THEIR CAMPUSES.
ALRIGHT I KNOW THAT -- I KNOW
THAT IT'S THE AMOUNT REQUESTED
IN THIS PROPOSAL FOR THE CSU
TRUSTEES WAS SEVENTY FIVE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S.
AT JANUARY BUDGET FORTY FIVE
CENTER STILL AND ASK THEIR CELL
WILL KEEP THIS -- UNDER
CONSIDERATION AS WE TAKE A LOOK
AT REVENUES FROM THE NEW REVISED.
THANK YOU WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE
OPEN AS WELL.
WITH THAT WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
THREE UPSTART YES THIS PLEASE
TAKE THEIR ALL.
MCCARTY HERE BRO.
MEDINA HERE O'DONNELL.
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED
[inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY SHE NUMBER THREE
COMPENSATION AND OTHER
OPERATIONAL COSTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
ONE HUNDRED NINETY THREE MILLION
ON GOING GENERAL FUND FOR
OPERATIONAL COSTS AT THE CSU.
THIS FUNDING WILL SUPPORT
CRITICAL OPERATIONAL NEEDS
IDENTIFIED BY THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES.
INCLUDING CONTRACTUALLY
OBLIGATED COMPENSATION NON
SALARY COST INCREASES AND OTHER
OPERATIONAL COSTS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
HELLO SIR THIS CERTAIN.
ISSUE REPRESENTS THE SINGLE
LARGEST PROPOSED COST INCREASE
FOR CSU HUNDRED NINETY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS.
AS THE AGENDA NOTES ON PAGE
FIFTEEN ISSUE COMPRISES SALARY
COSTS.
WHICH DEPARTMENT FINANCE JUST
NOTED AS WELL AS FOR OTHER BASIC
COST PRESSURES FACING THE
SEGMENT -- THIS RETIREMENT COSTS
HEALTHCARE COSTS COSTS OF FOR
THE HIKE IN THE STATE'S TO COVER
THE HIKE IN THE STATE'S MINIMUM
WAGE.
AND COSTS FROM OPENING UP NEW
FACILITY SPACE IN THE BUDGET
YEAR.
SO AS FAR AS THE SALARY COSTS.
THAT WOULD MAKE UP A HUNDRED AND
FORTY EIGHT THAT MAKES UP A
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT MILLION OF
THE PROPOSED HUNDRED NINETY
THREE MILLION.
AND THAT'S FOR REPRESENTED DOWN
ON REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY FOR THE MOST
PART THESE MONIES WOULD FIND
CONTINUING BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
THAT THE CSU BOARD OF TRUSTEES
RATIFIED IN PRIOR YEARS.
AND WITH CONTRACTS GENERALLY
BECOMING OPEN AT THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY THE
LEGISLATURE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
IN THE BUDGET YEAR TO SIGNAL
WHAT IT THINKS IS REASONABLE TO
FINE TUNE BARGAINING CONTRACTS.
420-002-0214 EXAMPLE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD SIGNAL ITS
EXPECTATION THAT CSU SALARY
INCREASES BE ALIGNED WITH
PROJECTED INFLATION THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO USE THE
RESULTS OF THAT.
ANY CSU COMMISSION FACULTY AND
STAFF COMPENSATION ANALYSIS TO
GUIDE LEGISLATURE'S FUNDING
DECISIONS.
THANK YOU.
A RAINSTORM AGAIN WITH C. ISSUE --
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OBVIOUSLY OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL -- THE
PROPOSAL IN THIS AREA THAT TO
COVER COMPENSATION INCREASES FOR
NINETEEN TWENTY AS WELL AS THE
MANDATE WHAT WE CALL OUR
MANDATORY COSTS WHICH COVER
HEALTH CARE AND THOSE THINGS
MENTION BY MR STING HOUSING.
THOSE ARE ALL PERFECTLY ALIGNED
WITH OUR BUDGET REQUEST IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT WE'VE DONE TO
FIGURE OUT.
WHAT OUR COMPETITION COSTS WILL
BE AS WELL AS A LOT OF THE
RETIREMENT COSTS AND OTHER OTHER
MENTOR COSTS?
SO WE'RE DEFINITELY VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS ENDEAVOR I
WILL SAY THAT -- FROM FROM FROM
COMPARING THIS ADMINISTRATION TO
THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION IS
INCREDIBLY ENCOURAGING AND
HELPFUL TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
THAT ARE PRESSING AND AND UPON
US OF THE SEA ISSUE WHICH IS.
COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN ALREADY
LOCKED IN AGREEMENTS AS WELL AS
A MENTOR ACOSTA INCREASES THAT
OCCUR BECAUSE OF RATE INCREASES
FOR HEALTHCARE FOR EXAMPLE THAT --
IN STOOD BY CALPERS AS WELL AS
RICK -- RETIREMENT RATE
INCREASES SO VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF THE FACT THAT THOSE.
THOSE KIND OF THOSE BASS LINE
ITEMS ARE COVERED IN IN IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
SO THIS IS -- PROPOSAL FULLY
COVERS THE THAT CONTRACT WITH
THE FACULTY TWO YEARS AGO
ANOTHER BARGAINING UNITS THAT'S
CORRECT WITH THAT WOULD THAT HOW
LONG IS THAT CONTRACT ON THE FOR
ALL OF WELL I'D SAY MOST OF THE
CONTRACTS ARE GOING TO RUN
THROUGH AYE.
NINETEEN TWENTY TO NINETEEN
TWENTY SO THE THE LA WAS WARNED
US THAT THE ECONOMY IS NOT GOING
TO KEEP.
GOING AT THE SAME CLIP.
AND OUT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN NEXT
YEAR IF WE HAD.
NOT A CUT IN AND MONEY IN THE
BUDGET BUT FLAT AMOUNTS.
SO HOW DO WE FIND OUR OUR OUR
CORE COSTS INCLUDING
COMPENSATION HEALTH CARE AND
WORKS ARE YOU ANTICIPATING THIS
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEAR
OR IF YOU I'M JUST SAYING
HYPOTHETICALLY IN IN THE THIS IS
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BY.
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET TALK
ABOUT SORT TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR
HERE YOU'RE FROM NOW ON WE DON'T
HAVE THE IF INCREASES WERE NOT.
WE DON'T HAVE A A CUTS RISE
REDUCTION IN CSU FUNDING LET'S
SAY IT'S A FLAT LINE SAY IT'S
FLAT.
I CAN ANTICIPATE HOW COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING WILL SHAKE OUT FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEAR BUT
OBVIOUSLY IF THERE ISN'T ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO INCREASE --
COMPENSATION IT WOULD BE VERY
HARD FOR US TO PROVIDE ANY SORT
OF COMPENSATION TO ANY OF OUR
STAFF BUT HOW WOULD YOU HONOR.
THE CONTRACTS THAT ARE THROUGH.
THAT YEAR.
WELL.
I THINK UNDER THE SCENARIO
YOU'RE YOU'RE SUGGESTING WOULD
BE IF THE BOTTOM FELL OUT OF THE
NAY REVISION OF REVENUES AND WE
HAVE A BUDGET PLAN IN NINETEEN
TWENTY WHERE WE COULD FIND IS
THAT.
IS THAT KIND OF THE ASSUMPTION
OR IS IT BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE.
THE THE THE COST THAT WE HAVE
ANTICIPATED ARE FOR THE NINETEEN
TWENTY YEAR NO I'LL TELL YOU
OFFER TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE A
YEAR FROM NOW OKAY I WITH THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET OKAY --
WE DON'T HAVE ANYBODY UNDER
CONTRACT -- FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND SO PRESUMABLY -- ALL.
MOST COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS ARE GOING TO BE SUN
SHINING OR OPENING UP ADDITIONAL
PROPOSALS THIS SUMMER.
AS WELL AS THE INTO THE WINTER
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEAR --
SO IF THE REVENUES ARE FLAT OR
DOWN.
AND IT IS A STRONG THERE'S
STRONG SIGNAL FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION OR THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING COMING THE
WAY OF SEE ISSUE.
THAT IT WOULD BE HARD FOR US TO
EVEN CONTEMPLATE.
INCREASE YOU KNOW INCREASING
COMPETITION BY.
ANY AMOUNT BUT THAT'S ALL VERY
HYPOTHETICAL AND IT IT'S IT'S
HARD TO SAY AT THIS POINT HOW WE
WOULD LAND OBVIOUSLY IT.
IT WILL.
ULTIMATELY BE A NEGOTIATED
BETWEEN THE LABOR -- OF FOLKS AS
WELL AS THE C. ISSUE IN TERMS OF
WHAT.
CAN AND CANNOT BE DONE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DEPENDING ON THE
REVENUE PICTURE [inaudible]
OKAY.
I KNOW THEY'LL HAVE SOME PUBLIC
COMMENT AS FAR AS YOUR SOME OF
YOUR OTHER -- UNITS AS AS WELL
AS ON THE ISSUE AS FAR AS
COMPENSATION MR MEDINA.
IF YOU COULD TO SEE ISSUE IF YOU
COULD REFRESH MY MEMORY I'M NOT
REMEMBERING IF CSU HAS
IMPLEMENTED YET THE STEP
INCREASES TO FACULTY.
IT IS NOT.
SO SO THAT'S NOT INCLUDED IN
THIS.
NO NO THIS IS A THAT WHAT'S
INCLUDED HERE -- FOR FOR THE
FACULTY IT -- GROUP IS -- A
GENERAL SALARY INCREASE. FOR FOR
THE NINETEEN TWENTY YEAR THERE'S
NO A STEP OR ANY ANY ANYTHING OF
THAT NATURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER BROWN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND PLEASE INDULGE I'M NEW TO
THIS COMMITTEE ONE MONTH -- SO.
TO SEE IT CSU BOARD NEGOTIATED
TO THE BARGAINING UNIT AND AND
COMES UP WITH A DEAL AND THEN
YOU COME TO THE LEGISLATURE ASKS
US TO FUND IT.
IT KIND OF PUTS US IN A BAD
SITUATION WHERE.
IF WE DON'T WE LOOK LIKE THE BAD
GUYS ON THE BOARD.
NOW ALL WE TRIED BUT THEY
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE OF THE
BUS HAS THAT ALWAYS BEEN THE
CASE OR INCIDENT THAT WE GIVE
YOU.
A PART OF MONEY AND THEN THE C.
ISSUE WOULD. TO PAY AND
FACILITIES AND MAINTENANCE
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE SYSTEM WE
JUST EDUCATE ON HOW THAT YEAH
IT'S WE WOULD -- WE WOULD AGREE
WITH YOU THAT IS IT THAT A TOUGH
POSITION TO BE AND KIND OF
COMPARING SEE ISSUE TO THE STATE
SO THAT SO THE STATE HAS.
HAS THE ABILITY TO KNOW HOW MUCH
FUNDING IT COULD PUT TOWARDS
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
GOING FORWARD AND HAS.
MULTI YEAR ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
WHAT REVENUE PICTURES ARE.
CAN ALSO NEGOTIATE WITH WITHIN
THE SAME REALM KNOWING HOW MUCH
MONEY IT HAS AND KNOWING WHAT
TERMS THAT CAN PROVIDE IN TERMS
OF ITS.
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
SEE SHE WAS IN A TOUGH SITUATION
WHERE WE HAVE FOR AS LONG AS CAN
BE.
IMAGINED WE'VE BEEN WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN.
ON BEHALF BUT THAT'S A IT'S A
HARD SITUATION TO BE IN BECAUSE
WE TYPICALLY IS A STATE OR AS A
SEASHORE LIVING OUT A YEAR BY
YEAR IN TERMS OF FUNDING RIGHT
SO.
WE IN A IN ESSENCE HAVE TO BET
ON THE COME SO TO SPEAK IN OUR
IN OUR LONGER TERM COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS.
THAT THE STATE WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING -- GENERALLY
SPEAKING THOUGH IN THE SINCE THE
GREAT RECESSION OUR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS HAVE --
CLOSELY BEEN ALIGNED WITH THE
RATE OF INFLATION -- MAYBE A
TOUCH A LITTLE BIT HIGHER THAN
THAT BUT BUT IT'S IT'S IT'S THE
WE ARENEGOTIATING CONTRACTS
WHERE.
WE ARE PUTTING YOU IN A IN A
SPOT WHERE I THINK IT'S
UNREASONABLE TO ASSUME THAT WE
WOULD BE -- PLACING YOU IN A
FIVE OR 6% INCREASE YEAR OVER
YEAR KIND OF SITUATION SO IT IS
A CHALLENGE FOR US FRANKLY --
BECAUSEONE IF YOU'RE
NEGOTIATING YOUR TO OR YOU'RE
THREE AND YOU'RE.
CONTEMPLATING YOUR ONE IN TERMS
OF WHETHER THE STATE'S GOING TO
FUND THOSE AGREEMENTS IT IS A
CHALLENGING POSITION TO BE IN
BUT THAT'S THE WAY IT'S BEEN FOR
MANY MANY YEARS.
SO YOU MENTIONED THAT NO ONE'S
UNDER CONTRACT IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IS THAT TYPICALLY HOW YOU
NEGOTIATE IS AT A YEAR BY YEAR
FIVE YEAR TEN YEAR DEAL.
IT DEPENDS ON THE SEASON --
PROBABLY IN THE LAST FORTY FIVE
YEARS THERE'S BEEN A CONCERTED
EFFORT TO TRY TO NEGOTIATE
LONGER TERM AGREEMENT SO A
MAXIMUM ABOUT THREE YEARS.
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN INSTANCES IN
THE PAST WHERE THEY'VE JUST BEEN
YEAR BY YEAR AGREEMENTS.
OBVIOUSLY YOU YOU PROBABLY DO
KNOW THAT THE TRADE OFFS -- YOU
KNOW A YEAR OR TWO YEAR CONTRACT
JUST REQUIRES A LOT OF EXTRA
WORK IN TERMS OF NEGOTIATION AND
AMONG THE PARTIES.
AND HAVING A START UP THAT
NEGOTIATION OVER AND OVER AGAIN
YEAR AFTER YEAR THAT'S THAT'S A
LOT OF WORK IN A BIG CHALLENGE --
SO MOST PEOPLE PREFER TO HAVE A
A SHORTER -- SHORT TERM OR MAYBE
A SEMI LONGER TERM AGREEMENT.
OF ABOUT THREE YEARS BUT IT'S
GOING TO ALWAYS DEPEND ON A LOT
OF FACTORS IT'S GOING TO DEPEND
ON WHAT THE APPETITE IS FOR
MULTI YEAR AGREEMENTS GOING TO
AND ON THE FISCAL SITUATION
STATE CALIFORNIA -- THE SORTS OF
THINGS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN AS WELL.
ISSUE NUMBER FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY
AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
RANDI KATZ SAID THE PART OF
FINANCE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY.
CONSISTENT WITH AUTHORITY
PROVIDED IN EDUCATION CODE
SECTIONS 897-728-9770.
FOUR CS I GUESS I SHOULD'VE
WAITED FOR YOU TO CALL ME --
SIDE.
CONSISTENT WITH THE FORTY CS YOU
MAY USE IT SUPPORT APPROPRIATION
FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
ADDRESSING NEEDS OF FACILITIES
THAT SERVE ACADEMIC PROGRAMS.
IN ADDITION THIS A TORTILLA
ALLOWS YOU SEE OUR CSU TO
FINANCE THE COST OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS OF ACADEMIC
FACILITIES THE RELATED
INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY SINCE YOU
SUBMITTED TWENTY TWO CAP OUT
LATER QUESTS INCLUDING STATE
WHAT INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS --
CONSISTENT WITH FUNDING
AVAILABLE AVAILABILITY APPROVED
BY TRUSTEES IN 200-016-2000
EIGHTEEN FINANCES PROVIDED
PRELIMINARY APPROVAL FOR ELEVEN
QUALIFYING PROJECTS AND SYSTEM
MIGHT INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS AS REFLECTED ON
PAGE NINETEEN OF THIS AGENDA.
A CURRENT LAW LIMITS ISSUES
CAPITAL EXPENDITURES TO NO MORE
THAN 12% OF ITS SUPPORT
APPROPRIATIONS NOTED THAT
SERVICE -- ONCE FUNDED --
PROJECTED MAXIMUM PERCENTAGE
WILL BE NINE POINT 7% ABOUT HALF
ON DEBT SERVICE AND HALF CASH
FUNDING. FOR THE SAN DIEGO
DRAMATIC ARTS INNOVATION PROJECT
A FINANCE NOTES THAT CS USE US
BASED GUIDELINES AUTHORIZED ALL
CAMPUSES WITH ENROLLMENT
EXCEEDING FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS
SUCH AS THE ISSUE SAN DIEGO.
THAT BOTH A FIVE HUNDRED SEAT
SMALL THEATER AND A BLACK BOX
THEATRE.
THE SECOND BLACK BOX THEATRE
ALLOWS FOR MULTIPLE STAGE
CONFIGURATIONS GIVEN THE
FLEXIBILITY THE HOST -- THAT
DOES PRODUCTION SUCH AS THE
TURNED AROUND OR RECITALS OR
DANCES THAT MAY NOT WORK AS WELL
IN THE TRADITIONAL THEATER.
IN ADDITION TO THE CAP OUT WHEN
ED CODE SECTION EIGHT NINE SEVEN
SEVEN THREE THE GOVERNOR EXT --
BUDGET PROPOSES TWO HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN MILLION AND ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OR TO IMPROVE AND
EXPAND CAMPUS BASED CHILD CARE
FACILITY INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT STUDENT PARENTS --
REGARDING THE PROPOSED THAT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WE'RE HAPPY
TO WORK LEGISLATIVE STAFF TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION REGARDING
THE PROPOSED DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDING.
ASSOCIATED PROJECTS TO ANSWER
THE SPENDING THAT SHE DESIRED
OUTCOMES HOWEVER.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
ARE GENERALLY FUNDED FROM
DEPARTMENTS BASED BUDGETS
DEPARTMENTS DO NOT TYPICALLY
PROVIDE SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
ON THESE PROJECTS AND RELATED
EXPENDITURES.
ALSO AND MAYBE MORE BENEFICIAL
AND INFORMATIVE FOR STAFF IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO REQUEST THE
INFORMATION FROM THE APARTMENTS
ON AN AS NEEDED BASIS.
WITH REGARDS TO DEPARTMENTS ARE
PROJECTS WHERE THERE MAY BE A
SPECIFIC INTEREST OR CONCERN
RATHER THAN IMPOSING A BROAD
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENT AS PROPOSED IN THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LA -- PAGE NINETEEN OF
YOUR GENDER LIST THE PROJECTS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAS PRELIMINARILYAPPROVED AND
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO LEGISLATIVE
REVIEW.
CSU INDICATES A CAN FINANCE
THESE PROJECTS WITHIN ITS
EXISTING BUDGET TO TO DO TO DEBT
REFINANCING OTHER ACTIONS IS
MISTER KATZ MENTIONED.
WE GENERALLY DON'T HAVE ANY
ISSUE WITH THE PROJECTS LISTED
WE DO RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERED THE TRADE OFFS OF THE
PROPOSED THEATER PROJECTS AT THE
SAN DIEGO CAMPUS.
THE PROJECT ENTAILS RENOVATING
AN EXISTING THEATER TO MAKE IT
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEN
CONSTRUCTING A NEW SECOND
THEATER AT AN ADJACENT LOCATION.
BY BUILDING A SECOND THEATER THE
CAMPUS SAYS IT'LL BE ABLE TO
MAIN STAGE MULTIPLE PERFORMANCES
AT THE SAME TIME.
SO THE CAMPUS PROPOSAL DOES NOTE
THAT -- THAT AN ALTERNATIVE
WOULD BE JUST TO RENOVATE THE
EXISTING THEATRE WITHOUT ADDING
THE SECOND THEATER.
AND THIS ALTERNATIVE WHICH WOULD
COST ABOUT SEVENTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS LESS ABOUT HALF THE COST
OF THE COMBINED.
RENOVATION A NEW THEATER
PROPOSAL SO IN THE IN ASSESSING
THE PROPOSAL.
THE GOOD LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
WEIGH THE TRADE OFFS.
IN THE BENEFIT OF HAVING TO
THEATERS TO STAGE MULTIPLE
PERFORMANCES WHETHER THAT
OUTWEIGHS THE ADDITIONAL COST
ANOTHER POSSIBLE PROJECTS THE
COULD BE FUNDED WITH. SEVENTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROPOSAL
PROVIDING ONE TIME MONIES.
THE GOVERNOR HAS SAID PROPOSAL
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FOR
NUMBER OF AGENCIES THIS YEAR.
WE DO THINK THAT FINDING
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS A GOOD
USE OF ONE TIME RESOURCES.
AS YOU SEE ON PAGE TWENTY OF THE
AGENDA WE DO THINK THAT MORE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
WOULD BE WARRANTED THAT WOULD
INCLUDE KNOWING AHEAD OF TIME
THE SPECIFIC PROJECTS THAT CSU
INTENDS TO UNDERTAKE AND CSU IS
WELL ON THEIR WAY AND PROVIDING --
GOOD UNDERSTANDING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE ON THOSE PROJECTS IT
WOULD LIKE -- TO FUND -- ALSO WE
RECOMMEND -- THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
REPORT AFTERWARD ON THE STATUS
OF OF THE PROJECT WHETHER THEY
WERE COMPLETED.
AND THEN ALSO FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO WORK WITH CSU TO
DEVELOP A LONG TERM PLAN. TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AND JUST TO
IMPROVE.
CS USE MAINTENANCE PRACTICES
GOING FORWARD SO YOU DON'T HAVE
ANOTHER BACKLOG DEVELOP IN A
NUMBER OF YEARS.
THE GOVERNOR HAS A PROPOSAL.
THAT WOULD ALLOW CAMPUSES TO USE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE MONEY FOR
OUR CAMPUS CHILD CARE FACILITIES.
OF ON THIS ONE THE LEGISLATURE
WILL JUST WANT TO KNOW BASIC
INFORMATION WHICH WHICH PROJECTS
WOULD NEED WHAT I NEED TO BE
FUNDED AND WHY WHAT THE
JUSTIFICATION IS THE COST THE
LOCATION.
REALLY JUST THE SAME BASIC
INFORMATION LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
ASSESS ANY FACILITIES PROJECT
REQUEST THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING VICE AND ONE
SISTER VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
CAPITAL PLANNING DESIGNING
CONSTRUCTION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR.
THE THE THE LA ALL RIGHT UP
NOTES AND AND MISTER KATZ IS
NOTED THE AUTHORITY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IN STATE GRANTED THE
CSU TO USE OUR OWN FUNDS TO GET
FUND CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS AND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS.
AND WHAT WE HAVE DONE SINCE THAT
TIME IS IN OUR FIVE YEAR PLAN
HAS PROVIDED INFORMATION ON WHAT
WE HAVE FUNDED FROM.
NOT ONLY THE PROJECTS USING OUR
OWN FUNDS BUT ALSO THOSE
PROJECTS APPROVED TO THE
CAMPUSES USING THE STATE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE DOLLARS.
SO THAT'S SUB ABOUT NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE LAST FEW
YEARS SO WHAT ARE FIVE YEAR PLAN
WE REPORT.
THOSE PROJECTS AT BUDGET LEVEL
SO IT'S NOT THE ACTUAL SAID THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S RECOMMENDS
BUT WE DO REPORT THAT NOW.
AND ALSO INCLUDES ACADEMIC
PROJECTS IN SELF SUPPORT
PROJECTS SO THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT -- WE DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH DOING IT MORE DIFFICULT
WITH.
OF FINANCIAL ACTUAL SPORTS COULD
CERTAINLY DO THAT.
THE TRUSTEES FOLLOW THE
PRIORITIES AS FAR AS CAPITAL
OUTLAY THAT -- THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
RECOMMENDS.
AND WE'VE BEEN FUNDING IN AN
AMOUNT OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
USE THEIR OWN FUNDS AND IT
REDUCE IT BY ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION.
IN OUR FIVE YEAR PLAN WE ALSO IS
AN ATTEMPT TO INCREASE THE
CAMPUS AWARENESS WE PUBLISH THE
BACKLOG BY CAMPUS WE PUBLISH AND
HOW MUCH THEY SHOULD BE FUNDING
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS.
AND HOW MUCH THEY WOULD HAVE TO
FUND TO ELIMINATE THE BACKLOG.
SO THAT WOULD GO FROM AND AN
ANNUAL NEED OF ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION JUST
TO CHIP AWAY AT THE BACKLOG.
BUT TO ELIMINATE IT COMPLETELY
OVER TIME WOULD RAISE IT TO OVER
SIX HUNDRED MILLION.
SO AS FAR AS THE CSU PLANNED
COMING UP WITH SIX HUNDRED
MILLION IS NOT VERY EASY GIVEN
OUR OUR PRIORITIES IN A SYSTEM
IN COMPETING NEEDS.
AS MENTIONED EARLIER TODAY AS
FAR AS ENROLLMENT COMPENSATION
BRAD INITIATIVE BUT WE ARE
CERTAINLY SOME OF THE PRIEST OF
OF THE ONE TIME FUNDS THE TWO
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN MILLION
INCLUDING IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
BUT WE CAN ALSO USE THE THE
PERMANENT BASE FUNDS OF EIGHTY
MILLION THAT WAS NOT INCLUDED
BUT CERTAINLY WOULD BE ABLE TO
HELP US FIND ADDITIONAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OVER TIME.
WITH REGARD TO THE CHILD CARE
CENTERS WE DO HAVE A RANGE OF
CAMPS IS REQUESTING DOLLARS FROM
A HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR PROJECT
ABOUT THIRTY MILLION SO WE ARE
STILL COLLECTING INFORMATION AND
HELP TO COME BACK TO LATER THIS
THE SPRING WITH MORE INFORMATION.
AND A FIRE FINAL PRIORITIES.
AS OF THE LA -- MENTION WE DO
HAVE THE PRIORITY LIST IN -- IN
THE WORKS FOR THE TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY SEVEN MILLION FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THAT'S ONE
OF THE SPEND SOURCES WE HAVE FOR
THAT WE'VE ASKED.
FOR BECAUSE WE TAKE A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH APPROACH WITH
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NATALIE
USING OUR FUNDS THROUGH
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS BUT
ASKING FUNDS FOR THE STATE AS
FAR AS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
AND THEN LEVERAGING THOSE
DOLLARS TO GET THE CAMPUS TO
FUND THAT ADDITIONAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OUT OF THEIR OWN
OPERATING BUDGET.
SO IT IS IT IS A DIFFICULT --
CHALLENGE IT'S BEEN WITH US AND
ONLY GROWING SINCE I'VE WORKED
FOR THE CSU BUT AM HAPPY -- FOR
THE FUNDING THAT'S IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND AND
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT HAPPY
ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
MR O'DONNELL YES THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF IT IS FROM A
IF WE BACK UP MY CONCERN WITH
THE CSU SYSTEM AS A WHOLE
CERTAINLY THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
AND THAT'S IS SIGNIFICANT ISSUE
BUT ALSO THE MANAGEMENT OF OUR
FACILITIES IN OTHER WORDS THE
PLANNING.
NOT NECESSARILY THE MICRO LEVEL
WHAT HAPPENS EVERY DAY -- BUT
BUT THE PLANNING AND I BRING THE
PERSPECTIVE OF ONE OF GRADUATING
CSU TWICE MY BACHELOR'S OR
MASTER'S I'M A FAN -- AND BUT I
WALK THROUGH LONG BEACH STATE
JUST ABOUT EVERY DAY WHEN I'M AT
HOME.
THE DOG EARLY IN THE MORNING SO
I SEE WHAT'S GOING ON THERE --
AND VARIETY REASONS BUT BUT
AGAIN DO YOU DO YOU HAVE A
CENTRAL CLEARINGHOUSE FOR THE
PLANNING OF FACILITIES ON THE
CSU CAMPUS.
SO ON A CAMPUS -- CHEN LINES I
WANT PLAN SOMETHING IS IT CLEAR
TO SOME OTHER LEVEL OTHER THAN
JUST DECIDED AT THE CAMPUS LEVEL.
IT COMES THROUGH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE CAPITAL
PLANNING DESIGN CONSTRUCTION.
SO WE BRING WE COLLECT ALL THE
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS FROM THE
CAMPUSES WE CREATE A FIVE YEAR
PLAN BASED ON WHAT THEY SUBMIT.
AND THEN PRESENT A RECOMMENDED
PRIVATIZATION TO THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AND THAT IS OUR MASTER
PLAN FOR EACH CAMPUS THERE IS A
MASTER PLAN IN OUR FIVE YEAR
PLAN AS WELL.
SO WHAT ABOUT WHEN I CAMPUS SIZE
THEY WANT TO BUILD SOMETHING
WITH -- MAYBE THE RACE AND
DOLLARS FOR BUILDING IT'S NOT
AND I WOULD SAY IT'S NOT EVEN A
CORE FUNCTION.
WITH WITH THAT GO THROUGH THE
THIS SENIOR LEVELS IF YOU WILL.
ANYTHINGOVER 700-100-0700 NINE
THOUSAND WHICH IS THE DEFINITION
FOR MINOR CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECT
COMES THROUGH THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ONE OF MY CONCERNS ONE OF
THINGS I'M NOTICING IN MAY AND I
COULD BE WRONG SO PLEASE CORRECT
ME.
AS I SEE A LOT OF EFFORT GOING
INTO RAISING MONEY FOR SOMETHING
THAT MIGHT BE A NOT COR FOR A
NON CORE FUNCTION LIKE AN ALUMNI
CENTER LOBBY STATE.
WAS VERY CONTROVERSY ON LARRY
AND I'LL GET TO THAT -- SO A LOT
OF MONEY RACE FOR THAT BUT THEN
THERE WILL BE -- BUILDING LIKE
MOMMY STATE PETERSON HALL THAT'S
IN NEED OF WORK.
AND I DON'T REALLY SEE AN EFFORT
ASSOCIATE THE RAISING DOLLARS
FOR THAT -- MAYBE PUTTING
SOMEONE'S NAME ON IT FINE WITH
ME WE GO ACROSS MANY CAMPUS
UNIVERSITIES NON CSU NON USE
EVEN YOU SEE THAT HAVE DIFFERENT
NAMES ON THEM BECAUSE THE MONEY
THAN RACE BUT THERE.
THEY SPEAK TO THE CORE FUNCTION
OF THE UNIVERSITY THEIR
EDUCATION RELATED.
BUT WHAT I'M SAYING IS MAYBE
SOME THAT AREN'T NECESSARILY YOU
KNOW IT'S A CORE FUNCTION CAN
YOU SPEAK TO THAT.
I WOULD SAY THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN BUILDINGS DONORS ARE
MORE INTERESTED IN SUPPORTING.
THERE IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR
EXAMPLE TO GET DONOR FUNDS FOR
AN INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT.
SO IT MAY BE THAT AND ALUMNI
CENTER ATTRACTS MORE SUPPORT
FROM THE DONORS.
AND AT A PROJECT LIKE A PETERSON
REPLACEMENT IT MAY BE A NAMING
FOR THAT BUILDING THAT WOULD BE
THE OPPORTUNITY OR CERTAIN ROOMS
THE CAMPUSES ARE TRYING TO
INCREASE THE CO FUNDING FOR THE
PROJECTS WE'VE ASKED.
THEM TO PROVIDE A 10% CO FUNDING
SO WHETHER THAT'S DONOR FUNDS
FOR THEIR OWN IT'S A CHANCE TO
LEVERAGE THE STATE AND SEE IF
YOU DOLLARS WITH THEIR OWN.
AND I WOULD SAY SOMETHING LIKE
HELLO MY CENTERS A WANT
SOMETHING LIKE REDOING APPEARS
AND HALL WHATEVER IT MAY BE A
CORE EDUCATIONAL FACILITIES AND
NEED.
AND SO MY CONCERNS IT'S SINCE.
IS WHAT I'M NOTICING I COULD BE
INCORRECT SO PLEASE CORRECT ME
IF I'M WRONG.
IS IT JUST SEEMS TO BE A LOT OF
EFFORT FOCUSING ON THESE NON
CORE [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
FACILITIES AS OPPOSED.
TO THAT CORPS FACILITY WHICH
ISN'T IT IS IMMEDIATE AN
IMMEDIATE NEED OF ATTENTION.
IT MAY ALSO.
REFLECT THAT FOR ELEVEN I CENTER
WE WOULD NOT PRIORITIZE THAT
USING STATE DOLLARS OR CSU FUNDS.
BECAUSE IT'S NON ACADEMIC IT IS --
PART OF THE THE FACILITIES
CAMPUSES WANT TO ATTRACT DONORS
AND SUPPORT THEIR THEIR
POPULATION BASE BUT WHEN WE ASK
THE STATE FOR EIGHTY MILLION TO
FINANCE ACADEMIC FACILITIES THE
ALUMNI CENTER WOULD NOT BE WHEN
WE WOULD.
AYE AYE INVOLVED IN THAT BUT MY
MY WORRY IS THAT SOMETHING LIKE
THAT -- THE EFFORT THAT WOULD
SUCK UP ALL THE ENERGY GEE I
WANT THIS THING AS OPPOSED TO
YOU KNOW I WHAT MY WANT VERSUS
MY NEED MIKE MY MY CONCERN IS
THE AMOUNT OF EFFORT GOING INTO
WORK ON SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
AS OPPOSED TO MAYBE SPENDING
TIME ON A CORE FACILITY BUT
THAT'S GOOD THANK YOU AND I WALK
THROUGH THE UNIVERSITY MANY
TIMES ON A FRIDAY NOBODY'S THERE.
WHAT'S GOING ON ON THAT FRONT TO
INCREASE I MEAN WHEN I WENT TO
LONG BEACH STATE I WAS THERE ON
FRIDAYS.
BUT TODAY IT SEEMS LIKE THERE
AREN'T VERY MANY PEOPLE THERE ON
FRIDAYS WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
ADDRESS.
THE MAXIMUM USE THE FACILITIES
AND AS I UNDERSTAND IT IF YOU IF
YOU LOOK AT THE CS YOU'VE IS THE
CSU FACILITIES.
THEY'RE PRETTY HEAVILY AS I GET
THAT BUT PRETTY HEAVILY IS
MONDAY THROUGH THURSDAY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE WHAT'S GOING ON WITH.
WITH THAT I RESTATE CLASSES THEY
GO MONDAY WEDNESDAY FRIDAY.
WHEN IT HAPPENING OUT THERE THAT
I'M NOT AWARE FROM THIS?
I AGREE WE ARE ALSO TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE THE CAMPUS IS TO OPEN
UP THE CAMPUSES AND AND THREE OF
OUR TRUSTEES HAVE ASKED US. TO
TO LOOK AT NOT ONLY FRIDAYS BUT
SATURDAYS AND SUNDAYS AS WELL SO
ESPECIALLY WITH THE INCREASE
ENROLLMENT HOW WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE THE THE CAPACITY
PROVIDE ACCESS.
IT SAYS CERTAINLY THINK
SOMETHING THAT THE WOULD BE EASY
TO DO IF WE HAD THE SOMETIMES A
FACULTY WANTING TO TEACH THOSE
DAYS SO SOMETHING WE NEED TO
WORK ON A GOOGLE SEARCH A
FACULTY MEMBER SCHEDULES AND
THEN A MANAGEMENT.
PROGRAM.
TEENS I THINK WOULD HAVE THE SAY
ON THAT SORRY.
DEANS OF THE DEPARTMENT I
BELIEVE HAVE THE SAY ON THAT BEN
AND MIGHT VISITS ALREADY.
SCHEDULED WAS.
COVERAGE ON THE ACADEMIC SIDE
WILL AND AND BRIAN MAY ALSO HAVE
A RESPONSE BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON WE
RECOGNIZE THAT JUST A LOT OF
ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT.
I THINK THE OTHER THING TO ADD
TO IT IS IS THAT -- YOU KNOW --
A CAMPUS.
MOST OF OUR CAMPUSES ARNETT
CAPACITY.
RIGHT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT MAYBE
FRIDAYS OR SATURDAYS RIGHT NOT A
CAPACITY AND IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY BECAUSE OF A LOT OF
A LACK OF FACILITIES RIGHT WE
HAVE LOTS OF FACILITIES AND WANT
TO SPACE I THINK THE REAL
CHALLENGE.
IS BEING ABLE TO FUNDED THAT
CAPACITY SO IF.
IF -- WE HAVE I DON'T KNOW HOW
BIG LONG BEACH IS MASTER
PHYSICAL MASTER PLAN IS BUT IT
COULD BE FIVE OR TEN THOUSAND
MORE STUDENTS COULD PHYSICALLY
BE ON THAT PARTICULAR CAMPUS.
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES IN ORDER
TO OFFERED MISSION TO SO MANY
MORE STUDENTS WHICH WOULD MEAN
WE HAVE NOT ENOUGH ROOM.
ON ON MONDAY THROUGH THURSDAY SO
THAT WE CAN.
PUSH AND FRIDAYS AND SATURDAYS
AND OFFER MORE COURSES BECAUSE
THERE ARE THAT MANY STUDENTS AND
THAT MANY FACULTY THAT NEED
THOSE LIMITED RESOURCES SO.
IN LONG BEACH CASE IT MAY BE
THAT THEY JUST DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
FUNDING IN ORDER OFFER.
ALL THE COURSES -- THAT WOULD
NOT THEY HAVE A FUNDING OFFER
ALL THE EXISTING COURSES BUT
THEY COULD OFFER POTENTIALLY
MORE IF THERE WAS ADDITIONAL
ENROLLMENT FUNDING OR GRAD
MISSION OF FUNDING OFFERED WHERE
YOU WOULD SEE MUCH MORE TRAFFIC
PROBABLY ON A FRIDAY.
I DON'T THAT'S HELPFUL OR NOT
BUT THE BUT THE POINT IS TO SAY.
THAT -- YOU YOU NEED THE
OPERATING FUNDS IN ORDER TO FILL
THAT FACILITY.
UNDERSTOOD BUT ISN'T IT TRUE
THAT HE DID OFFER COURSES ON
FRIDAY SATURDAY AND SUNDAY.
THE PRESSURE ON THE FACILITIES
WE BE LESS AND ON AVERAGE.
SURE YEAH BUT YOU'RE STILL
INCREASING TOTAL HOURS OF USE
CRACKED AND I I RECOGNIZE THAT
BUT THEN THE NECESSITY TO BUILD
MORE FACILITIES.
THE PRESSURE TO BUILD MY MORE
FACILITIES MIGHT BE LESSEN
THAT'S RIGHT.
AND AND SO IT ON THE UNIVERSITY --
CAMPUS ARE ARE ARE THEY SHARING
SPACE.
I MEAN HOW HOW DOES THIS WORK
FOR THE THE LECTURE SPACES
TYPICALLY SHARED.
INTERDISCIPLINARY SPACE OF THE
LAB SPECIFIC TEACHING LAB UPPER
DIVISION MOST LIKELY DID NOT
EASILY SHARED BUT IN OUR OUR NEW
PROGRAMS WE'RE SEEING CAMPUSES
WANT GREATER INTERDISCIPLINARY.
MAKER PROJECTS SPACE WHERE THEY
CAN HAVE MORE COLLABORATION THAT
IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE'RE
SEEING IN A NUMBER OF THE CAMPUS
PROPOSALS.
OKAY AND THE U. S. -- FOR
GOVERNOR PROVIDES TWENTY FORTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FOR TO PAY
FOR CAMPUS BASED CHILD CARE
FACILITIES.
WITH A CHILD CARE FACILITY BE
SOMEWHAT OF AN ENTERPRISE FUND.
WE DON'T NECESSARILY WHEN SEE
ISSUES DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY.
TO SERVICE THEIR CORE FUNCTION
NOW ARE WE GONNA PUT THEM INTO
THE DAY CARE BUSINESS.
IT IS A BIT OF A MIXED MOST OF
THE CHILD CARE FOR STUDENTS ARE
THROWN THROUGH THE CELL SUPPORT
PROGRAM.
AND THIS WOULD BE FOR THE
FACILITY THEY WILL BE CAREFUL
THAT THOUGH THAT'S SAYING NO AS
MUCH AS WE NEED TO BE VERY
CAREFUL OF WE'RE GONNA.
START.
BUILDING CHILDCARE FACILITIES
ALL OVER THE CAMPUS WHEN WE
DON'T EVEN HAVE ADEQUATE
FACILITIES FOR THE STUDENTS.
WE NEED TO FIND THAT BALANCE
SENATE EITHER THEIR ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS AND CHILD DEVELOPMENT
KINESIOLOGY -- THAT HAVE
STUDENTS OF AS PART OF THEIR
CLASS ACADEMIC CURRICULUM.
BUT JUST TO JUST TO ADD TO THAT --
SIMMER O'DONNELL -- ONE THING
THAT WE WE WOULD WANT TO DO AS A
C. ISSUE SYSTEM IS OBVIOUSLY
DEDICATE MOST OF THAT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE TO THE ACADEMIC
PROGRAM THAT WE JUST WERE
DISCUSSING RIGHT -- WE ALSO
REALIZE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD LIKE.
A CHILD CARE FACILITIES TO HAVE
STE THAT THERE BE SOME FOCUS ON
THAT AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO
DOING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT BUT I
JUST WANT TO PUT OUT THERE THAT --
THAT THERE THERE SHOULD BE ANY
CONFUSION THAT WE WOULD.
WE WOULD SPEND SAY MAY MAYBE 50%
OF THIS FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AND THE OTHER HALF TO
ECONOMIC OUR PREFERENCE WOULD BE
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
FUNDING IS FOR THE ACADEMIC
FACILITIES AND FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS.
BUT WHEN VICE GROUP IS DONE
ASSESSING THE NEED OF THESE
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
CENTERS.
THAT IF THERE IS A DIRE NEED ON
A PARTICULAR -- FACILITY.
SIGNIFICANT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
OR OTHER ISSUE THEN WE WOULD BE
MORE THAN WILLING TO TO CONSIDER
THAT IN TERMS OF FUNDING PARTS
OF THAT.
CAN BE AND REMEMBER THOSE ARE
PROBABLY GONNA HAVE TO BE.
MAINTAINED IN A MUCH MORE
DIFFERENT FASHION IN THE TYPICAL
CLASSROOM.
IS IT NEW STATE STANDARDS BEING
DEVELOP YOU HAVE KIDS YOU HAVE
LITTLE KIDS ARE TOUCHING
EVERYTHING IS NOT LIKE YOUR
STANDARD CLASSROOM.
WHICH WE'VE LET GO.
SO I HAVE IT AND I KNOW PUT THAT
ON YOU THAT'S IT THAT'S A
FUNDING ISSUE WE HAVE WHAT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE SO WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT UPON FOR SURE.
BUT AGAIN FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
VERY LOCAL ISSUE I'M FACING ON
ALONG THE STATE CAMPUS IS A
PLACEMENT OF AN ALARM I CENTER
WHERE IT DOESN'T BELONG ABOUT
THE NEIGHBORS AT MY THROAT --
THE CAMPUS ISN'T BUILT OUT THERE
ARE OTHER PLACES TO PUT IT I'VE
MET WITH THE PRESIDENT THE
UNIVERSITY.
DIDN'T GET AN ANSWER I MET WITH
A CHANCE -- I DON'T WANNA KEEP
THIS CONVERSATION UP.
I WANT THIS PROBLEM I HAVE A
VERY LOCAL LEVEL FIXED I'VE GOT.
AGAIN THE ALUMNI CENTER THEN I
HEAR MAYBE A DORM ROOM
OVERLOOKING ELEMENTARY SCHOOL I
GOT THE PTA MOMS COMING AT ME.
A DORMS DON'T BELONG.
A YOU KNOW SAID ACROSS THE
STREET.
FROM A A MULTI STORY DORM SAID
ACROSS THE STREET FROM
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WITH A LOOK
DOWN.
UPON ELEMENTARY SCHOOL SO I
EXPECT AN ANSWER FROM THE CSU
SYSTEM.
I'VE I HAVE BEEN I THINK I'VE
DONE MY DUE DILIGENCE -- I'VE
GOT NEIGHBORS COMING AT ME AND I
THINK THEY'VE GOT.
A PRETTY LEGITIMATE PERSPECTIVE
WHEN THEY WERE PROMISED SOME
OPEN SPACE WHEN THE WHEN THE BIG
BLUE PYRAMID WAS BUILT YEARS AGO --
AND THEY WANT TO KEEP THAT OPEN
SPACE THERE THERE ARE MANY IN
OPEN SPACES ON THE CAMPUS I WANT
TO WORK WITH THE UNIVERSITY.
BUT I NEED THEM TO WORK WITH
WITH ME I'VE MET WITH THEM AND
AGAIN I DON'T WANT TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION AGAIN I DON'T WANT
THIS CONVERSATION. TO GET TIED
UP IN THE BUDGET BUT IT WILL OF
IT HAS.
TO THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTION MISTER -- WITH DONNA
YES I WENT TO LONG BEACH STATE I
KNOW HE LIVED IN THE EARL WARREN
DORMS HOW ARE THOSE THE DORMS
YOU TALK ABOUT I LIVE IN THE
EARL WARREN TORN OVER THERE.
WELL PARK SITE IS THAT THE ONE
THAT WILL MY UNDERSTAND IS A
THERE'S A PROTECT THEIR
POTENTIALLY GOING TO CONSTRUCT
ANOTHER MULTI STORY DORM --
ALONG AFTER TEN AT AND WHERE
THAT BECOMES PROBLEMATIC IS IT
OUT OF THE AREA AROUND THE
UNIVERSITY IS BUILT OUT THERE'S
HOMES THERE.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT YOU KNOW.
STUDENTS IN THE FOUR STORY OF
THEIR DORM LOOKING INTO THEIR
BACKYARDS.
AND THERE'S ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
THERE TOO AND THERE'S JUST.
AB IN A THAT THERE ARE PLACES TO
PUT IT I JUST DON'T THINK IT
SHOULD BE A PUTTING.
THE ATHERTON COURT OR THERE.
BUT I I WANT TO JUMP ON WHICH
YOU SAID -- MR O'DONNELL AYE I
KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT FOR FOCUSING
ON FACILITIES I SUPPORT DOING
THAT YEAH HI READ BOND.
I THINK THAT WOULD -- LEVY AT
SOME OF THE PRESSURE ON CSU AND
YOU SEE TO FREE UP SOME OF THAT
MONEY TO FOCUS ON ENROLLMENT AND
GRADUATION INITIATIVES AND THAT
WORKFORCE FACULTY ALL OUR OTHER
PRIORITIES.
BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT PROPERLY
UTILIZING.
OUR OUR FACILITIES.
ON EVENINGS ON FRIDAYS AND
WEEKENDS -- IF YOU LOOK AT THESE.
SCANDAL DRIVEN.
YOU KNOW THE NEWS FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES THE TO FRIDAYS AND
EMPTY EYES AND THE CURRENT THE
IS ONE OUT OF BUSINESS.
THE REASON THEY DID SO WELL IS
BECAUSE THEY'RE ABLE TO SERVE
STUDENTS AT THEIR TIMES AND IT
WASN'T ALWAYS MONDAY THROUGH
THURSDAY THE TYPICAL HOURS THAT
YOU KNOW MAYBE STUDENTS AND LOT
OF FACULTY WANT TO TEACH -- BUT
THEY'RE WORKING ON EVENINGS AND
FRIDAYS AND SATURDAYS AND SO I
THINK THAT.
THAT'S A LESSON TO US THAT
STUDENTS -- WANT TO GO TO GET
THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION AT
DIFFERENT TIMES.
AND SO I THINK WE NEED TO STEP
IT UP.
AND AND HAVE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THEIR FACULTY MEMBERS YOU
KNOW GET ON IT IN FOCUS AND
UTILIZING.
OUR CAMPUSES -- NO.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN AND INCLUDES
THE SUMMER MONTHS AS WELL.
OKAY WE'LL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN
ISSUE NUMBER -- FIVE CAMPUS
STUDY.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES TWO
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR THE CSU CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
TO UNDERTAKE A REVIEW OF A
POTENTIAL CAMPUS IN SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY LIKELY STOCKTON.
THE ADMINISTRATION ANTICIPATES
THAT THIS PROPOSED REVIEW WOULD
INCLUDE A STUDY THAT EXAMINES
WHETHER A POTENTIAL CAMPUS IS
MERITED IN THE AREA.
AND OUTLINING CONSIDERATIONS FOR
PRELIMINARY PLANNING IF SO.
FURTHER DETAILS ON THIS PROPOSAL
WILL BE PROVIDED WITH THE MAY
REVISION WITH UPDATED BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY LA OF AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST NOTED
THIS ISSUE IS MENTIONED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S.
JAN TEN BUDGET BUT WAS NOT
PROPOSED IN BUDGET BUILDER TRAIL
OF THE LEGISLATURE HASN'T SEEN
THAT LANGUAGE YET.
BUT COMING IT MAY REVISE IT
SOUNDS LIKE SO I'M THINKING
ABOUT.
THE INITIAL PROPOSAL WE OFFER
TWO ISSUES FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER.
THE FACT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSING FUNDS
FOR STUDY SUGGESTS THAT THE
GOVERNOR WOULD LIKE TO ASSESS
CERTAIN CRITERIA CERTAIN FACTORS
BEFORE COMMITTING TO A NEW
CAMPUS.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT YET
CLARIFIED WHAT FACTORS IT WOULD
LIKE TO CONSIDER SO WE'LL HAVE
TO LOOK FOR THAT AS PAGE TWENTY
THREE OF YOUR AGENDA NOTES.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE ASKED OUR OFFICE TO
ASSESS WHETHER A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY WAS JUSTIFIED BASED
ON ONE KEY FACTOR WHICH WAS
PROJECTED ENROLLMENT AND
PHYSICAL CAPACITY OF EXISTING
CAMPUSES.
IN THAT REPORT WE FOUND THAT THE
STATE COULD ACCOMMODATE GROWTH
IN MOST REGIONS INCLUDING THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BY BUILDING OUT
EXISTING CAMPUSES.
WITH THAT SAID THE
ADMINISTRATION MIGHT HAVE OTHER
FACTORS IN MIND -- WHICH MIGHT
INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE COMMUTING
TIME. FOR STUDENTS TO TRAVEL TO
A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY OR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OF THE LOCAL.
STOCKTON AREA SO LEGISLATURE
WILL WANT.
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHICH
FACTORS THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHEN
UNDERTAKING CAMPUS STUDY.
THE LEGISLATURE.
OF COURSE WILL ALSO WANT TO KNOW
WHAT EXACTLY THE PROPOSED STUDY
SCOPE WILL ENTAIL. FOR EXAMPLE
IS THE TWO MILLION DOLLARS
INTENDED TO COVER FACILITY PLANS
FINANCING PLANS DEVELOPMENT OF
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS.
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS SO
LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO BE
CLEAR ON WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PERFECT PROPOSED DELIVERABLES
ARE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO -- THE C. ISSUE HAS
ESTABLISHED POLICY DECADES AGO
ON ON HOW TO REVIEW -- THE IDEA
OF BRENDA CAMPUSES FOR THIS
ISSUE -- WITHIN THAT WE WOULD
OBVIOUSLY -- IF WE WERE TASKED
WITH THIS RESPONSIBILITY WE
OBVIOUSLY -- HELP GATHER THE
DATA WILL ANALYZE THE DATA SAYS
THE ALTERNATIVES -- WE PREPARE
FINAL REPORTS -- NO QUESTION
WE'VE DONE THIS IN THE PAST WITH
THE CHANNEL ISLANDS AND PRICE
SAN MARCOS AS WELL AND NUMBER IN
THE MOST RECENT PAST MONTEREY
BAY -- SO THIS WOULD THIS WOULD
BE NOTHING NEW IN TERMS OF OUR
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO CREATE A
NEW -- TRACK RECORD IN TERMS OF
HAVING TO CREATE -- A PROCESS TO
REVIEW THE NEED FOR NEW CAMPUS.%
SO I THINK WHERE IT WHERE IT
REALLY RESIDES IS IF YOU THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR AGREE
ON THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL -- I
THINK WHAT AND WHAT WILL
EVENTUALLY HAPPEN IS IS THAT THE
TASK IS WITH THAT RESPONSIBILITY
WERE WILLING TO DO THE WORK ON
IT.
THANK YOU I I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS HERE OUT I'M IN.
THE FULL SUPPORT OF OF A MORE
HIGHER EDUCATION SERVICES AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS LIKE LIKE THIS
SAM LOOKING AREAS. SEVEN CAN
COUNTY IN AND STOCKTON.
JUST THAT -- I KNOW THIS IS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND IT WAS A
PROPOSAL FROM THE CSU THE TWO
MILLION RIGHT.
RIGHT WAS A SOMETHING THAT YOU
HAD REQUESTED OR TALK ABOUT.
WE DIDN'T REQUEST THAT NATURE.
AND SO IF IT WAS YOUR PREFERENCE.
WHO WHAT DO YOU THINK SOME MORE --
EFFICIENT USE OF A COUPLE
MILLION BUCKS WHETHER IT'S TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE TO TO CREATE A
NEW CAMPUS -- WHEN THERE'S A
COUPLE JUST STUDENTS OR TO BUILD
THAT THE EXISTING OFF CAMPUS
CENTER?
AND FOCUSING ON FACILITIES AND
OF COURSE -- OFFERINGS IN
ADDITIONAL FULL TIME FACULTY.
AND CAL LOOKING AT THE MODEL.
OF SAN MARCOS VERY THE SET UP AN
OFF CAMPUS CENTER FROM SAN DIEGO
STATE AND WHEN THEY REACHED A
CERTAIN THRESHOLD HAVE TRIGGER
TO BECOME.
A FULL FLEDGED CSU CAMPUS.
WELL I THINK WHAT YOU'RE WHAT
YOU'RE REALLY GETTING IT THROUGH
THAT HERE'S THIS ACCESS RIGHT
DIGITAL ACCESS FOR STUDENTS
RIGHT.
SO -- IT'S THE MOST DIRECT WAY
TO DO THAT IS TO INCREASE
FUNDING ON THE GRANDEST OF SIDE
OR ON ENROLLMENT GROWTH RIGHT
THAT'S IMMEDIATE.
THING THAT CONNECT THAT THAT CAN
BRING IN NEW ACCESS TO THE
UNIVERSITY.
I THINK THE THE SITUATION WITH
MAYBE A STOCKTON CAMPUS WOULD BE
YOU IF IT THIS WILL BE A DELAYED
OR IT -- A PRO LONG TO SORT OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF YOU GETTING TO
ACCESS EVENTUALLY RIGHT SO YOU'D
HAVE TO FIRST START LOOKING AT
WHETHER THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
EXPANSION OF THE OFF CAMPUS
CENTER.
OR A BRAND NEW CAMPUS THEN IT
WOULD THAT ENTAIL LATER ON
ADDING FUNDING THROUGH GRAD IT
SHOULD HAVE WARNED ROME THE
GROWTH FOR ADDITIONAL ACCESS AT
THAT FACILITY SO IT'S REALLY
KIND OF A TRADE OFF. FOR YOU
FOLKS IF YOU WANT A INSTANT
GRATIFICATION SO TO SPEAK OF AN
INCREASING ENROLLMENT WITH THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING OR WHETHER
YOU WANT TO PLAN FOR THE FUTURE
AND BILL CAPACITY IN CERTAIN
REGIONS OF THE STATE SO IT'S I I
CAN'T GIVE YOU A RECOMMENDATION
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER -- IN TERMS
OF TO OUR FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
OF THE SEA ISSUE.
DICTATING OR SUGGESTING WHICH
WAY TO GO ON THIS IT'S IT'S IT'S
WITHIN YOUR PURVIEW OBVIOUSLY.
I'M LOOKING AT MY NOTES HERE AND
IT SAYS -- OTHER REQUEST MAY BE
PENDING [inaudible]
SO -- STOCKTON IS NOT THE ONLY
AREA IN THE PARK IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO IS INTERESTED IN
HAVING YOU CSU CAMPUSES.
SO MY QUESTION. TO ALL OF YOU.
WOULD BE IS THE TWO MILLION
DOLLARS PERHAPS OF PREMATURE.
GIVEN THAT THERE ARE OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE WHO ARE ALSO
INTERESTED.
IN HAVING CSU CAMPUSES -- MY
NOTES I HAVE.
THAT -- THERE'S INTEREST IN PALM
DESERT I KNOW THERE'S INTEREST
IN AND IN THE SAN DIEGO AREA AND
ANOTHER PART OF THE STATE SO MY
QUESTION TO ALL OF YOU.
IS THIS TWO MILLION DOLLARS
PERHAPS PREMATURE.
REQUEST.
THE THIRD WE ARE AWARE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION IS AWARE OF
INTEREST IN CSU CAMPUSES IN
OTHER REGIONS OF THE STATE WE'VE
SEEN POLICY BILLS IN RECENT
YEARS THAT I HAVE PROPOSED
SECTION VARIOUS AREAS -- THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO EXAMINE
A POTENTIAL NEW CAMPUS IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY AREA
SPECIFICALLY.
WAS REALLY DRIVEN BASED ON A
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT REAL
PERSONAL INCOME IN THAT AREA IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THAN THE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE.
AS WELL AS UNEMPLOYMENT BEING
NEARLY DOUBLE THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE BASED ON TWENTY
SEVENTEEN INFORMATION.
AND WE'VE SEEN IN THAT REGION AN
INCREASING OVERALL NUMBER OF
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES BUT A
LOWER THAN AVERAGE NUMBER.
WHO MEET REQUIREMENTS TO FOR
ADMISSION TO A YOU SEE OR CSU SO
IT WAS AN AREA THAT WAS
IDENTIFIED AS THE ADMINISTRATION
IS A PRIORITY FOR EXPLORATION OF
A POTENTIAL CAMPUS --
ACKNOWLEDGING AGAIN THAT THE
STUDY WOULD NOT NECESSARILY
PRESUPPOSE THAT THERE IS MERIT
HAVING THE CAMPUS THERE BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE INTERESTED
IN HAVING THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE LOOK AT A NUMBER OF
FACTORS OF THE BENEFITS.
POTENTIALLY OF LOCATING A CAMPUS
AS WELL AS WHAT THE PRELIMINARY
PLANNING WOULD LOOK LIKE IF THEY
WERE TO DO SO.
AND TO SPEAK TO SOME OF MISTER
STORMS EARLIER COMMENTS
REGARDING SORT OF SOME TRADE
OFFS BETWEEN ENROLLMENT FUNDING --
GRADUATION INITIATIVE FUNDING
PRIORITIES LIKE THAT THAT
INCREASE ACCESS COMPARED.
TO EXPANDING TO A NEW POTENTIAL
CAMPUS -- THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD SEE THOSE ALL IMPORTANT
PRIORITIES WHICH IS REFLECTED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE MADE
INVESTMENTS AND ALL OF THOSE
AREAS.
I THINK AND MAYBE JUST A CARBON
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME TO SEE
WHAT THE THE THE PROCEDURE OR
THE METHOD THAT WE USE. TO
DETERMINE WHERE CAMPUSES I
SHOULD BE BUILT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WHO IS BEST TO
DETERMINE WHERE THOSE CAMPUSES.
ARE NEEDED SO JUST A COMMON.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
I HAVE A A BRIEF -- QUESTION ARE
A FEW QUESTIONS -- HI I RECENTLY
SAW.
YOU JUST AS A POINT OF REFERENCE
THAT -- THAT CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION IS INCREASE I BELIEVE
IT WAS AROUND TWENTY TWENTY
THREE MILLION IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
AN HOUR APPROACHING FORTY
MILLION -- IT DURING DURING THE
PAST. FORTY YEARS -- HAMMER HOW
MANY NEW CAMPUSES HAS YES YOU
OPENED [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
AT LEAST FOR AT LEAST FOUR WEEKS.
FOR AND THE IF YOU HAVE A
BALLPARK SENSE AS TO LIKE --
HELP HELP -- MUCH -- ENROLLMENT
HAS INCREASED SINCE YES YOU IN
THE LAST FORTY YEARS.
WE WOULD HAVE TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT YEAH OKAY ALL RIGHT I MEAN
I I'M JUST TO YOU KNOW
[inaudible]
OFTEN.
WHEN WHEN I'M TALKING TO MY
CONSTITUENTS AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
ASKING ME ABOUT ELIZA SO MUCH
HARDER TO GET INTO COLLEGE IN IN
INTO OUR R. C. S. USING UC'S NOW --
THAN A WAS YOU KNOW A BACK IN
THE DAY WHEN THEY ATTENDED AND I
I ALWAYS TELL HIM WELL IT'S
PRETTY EASY OUR OUR STATE'S
POPULATION HAS DOUBLED IN THE
LAST FORTY YEARS BUT OUR
CAPACITY OR ARE HIGHER READ
CAPACITY IS NOT DOUBLE.
AND SO I I JUST WANTED -- TO IF
IT IF I CAN GET THAT.
NO INFORMATION NOW.
LATER THEIR THAT THAT WOULD BE
NICE -- SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS ON CAMPUS STUDY --
LIKE TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
SIX BASIC NEEDS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO ASSIST CSU CAMPUSES IN
THEIR EFFORTS TO ADDRESS FOOD
AND HOUSING AND SECURITY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN A SURVEY OF CSU STUDENTS
CONDUCTED THROUGHOUT
200-016-2000 17402% OF
RESPONDENTS REPORTED HAVING.
FOOD AND SECURITY ABOUT 11% OF
RESPONDENTS REPORTED
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITHIN
THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
AS PAGE TWENTY FOUR OF YOUR
GENDER NOTES RECENTLY THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED INCENTIVE
GRANTS FOR CAMPUSES. TO HELP
STUDENTS AND ROLL AND CAL FOR US
WHICH IS THE STATE'S FOOD STAMPS
PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS OPERATE FOOD PANTRIES
AND CREATE MEAL SHARING PROGRAMS.
IN ADDITION TO THESE PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES VARIOUS CAMPUSES
OFFER OTHER SUPPORTS AND
RESOURCES TO STUDENTS SUCH AS
EMERGENCY HOUSING.
AND HOUSING VOUCHERS.
SINCE YOU STUDY FOUND THAT AT
LEAST AT THE TIME MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES WERE UNDER
UTILIZED. FOR EXAMPLE THREE
QUARTERS OFSTUDENTS WHO ARE
IDENTIFIED BY RESEARCHERS AS
FOOD AND SECURE.
HAD NEVER HEARD OF OR NEVER USE
THE CAMPUS FOOD PANTRY YOUR
AGENDA ON PAGES TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE DESCRIBES OTHER
FINDINGS FROM CS USE LATEST
LEGISLATIVE REPORT ON THE ISSUE.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME MONEY
FOR BASIC NEEDS FOR PHIL CS USE.
BUDGET REQUEST AND CSU INDICATES
IT WOULD USE THE MONEY TO EXPAND
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL AGENCIES
AND NON PROFITS THAT SPECIALIZE
IN WORKING WITH FOOD IN SECURING
HOMELESS POPULATIONS.
AND IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE IDEA WOULD BE FOR THESE
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES TO STUDENTS
AND LINK THEM TO COMMUNITY
RESOURCES -- WE HAVE A FEW
ISSUES FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER HERE FIRST THE ISSUE OF
SUSTAINABILITY.
ASSUMING CAMPUSES ARE ABLE TO
USE THE PROPOSED FUNDS TO FORM
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO GET
CLARIFICATION ON HOW CSU PLANS
TO SUSTAIN THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
ONCE THE ONE TIME MONEY RUNS OUT.
SECOND THE LEGISLATURE MAY WISH
FOR CSU TO ESTABLISH CLEAR GOALS
TARGETS IN METRIC SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN ASSESS THE
IMPACT OF THE FUNDING THAT IT
PROVIDES FOR CSU.
THIRD THERE'S THE REALLY
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE ABOUT.
HOW CSU STUDENTS GET RESOURCES
TO GO TO COLLEGE YOU KNOW
FINANCIAL AID AS A PRIMARY WAY
STUDENTS COVER BASIC NEEDS SUCH
AS ROOM AND BOARD AND?
CURRENTLY THERE IS.
THERE ARE INEQUITIES AMONG THE
THREE SEGMENTS -- AND WHAT EIGHT
IS PROVIDED TO STUDENTS CSU
PROVIDES MORE AID FOR LIVING
COSTS AND CSU EXCUSE ME YOU SEE
PROVIDES MORE AID.
FOR CSU FOR EXAMPLE AND STUDENTS
AT CSU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS
A RESULT MAY HAVE TO WORK LONGER
HOURS FOR TAKE OUT MORE LOANS TO
COVER THE REMAINING COSTS.
A DESPITE YOU SEE HAVING THE
MOST RESOURCES FOR THEIR
STUDENTS UP FOR LIVING COSTS THE
GOVERNOR'S ONLY PROPOSING
ONGOING RESOURCES FOR YOU SEE
HE'S PROPOSING FIFTEEN MILLION.
ON GOING FOR YOU SEE FIFTEEN
MILLION ONE TIME FOR CSU AND NO
MISSION IS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SO GIVEN THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER WHETHER TO
PRIORITIZE ONGOING FINANCIAL AID
RESOURCES. FOR US YES YOU IN AND
SEE IT AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
FOR THAT MATTER. ONE WAY TO DO
THAT COULD BE. TO TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR CAL GRANT.
BE ACCESS AWARDS WHICH PROVIDES
MONEY FOR LIVING COSTS AND
SERVES A LARGE NUMBER OF A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN CSU
STUDENTS SO JUST SOME THINGS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO KEEP IN MIND
AS AN SS IS THIS.
PROPOSAL AND THIS -- PERSISTENT
PROBLEM THAT CSU AND OTHER
SEGMENTS ARE IDENTIFYING.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CSU.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS DENISE BADLY AND I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF STUDENT WELLNESS
IN THE BASIC NEEDS INITIATIVE
FOR THE CAL STATE SYSTEM.
THIS THIS IS BASICALLY THE NEEDS
INITIATIVE IS A SYSTEM WIDE
EFFORT TO COORDINATE -- SERVICES
ACROSS CAMPUSES TO HELP REACH
STUDENTS IN SUPPORT NEED OF
SUPPORT.
THE INITIATIVE IS STRUCTURED
AROUND A COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK
INVOLVING THE FIVE KEY AREAS OF
ADDRESSING IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS GROWING CAMPUS BASED
BASIC NEEDS SERVICES SO THEY CAN
REACH ADDITIONAL STUDENTS.
SCALING BEST PRACTICES FROM ONE
CAMPUS TO ACROSS THE SYSTEM
PARTNERSHIPS AND COLLABORATIONS
WITH LOCAL AGENCIES AND ENSURING
LONG TERM SUSTAINABILITY OF
BASIC NEEDS SERVICES.
AS AN EXAMPLE FOR STUDENTS
STRUGGLING WITH FOOD AND
SECURITY ALL TWENTY THREE OF OUR
CAMPUSES EITHER HAVE A FOOD
PANTRY OR FOOD DISTRIBUTION
PROGRAM.
ALL CAMPUSES PROVIDE CAL FRESH
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE TO
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS SO THAT THEY
MAY HAVE HEALTHY.
EATING OPTIONS IN FACT FROM
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO THE
END OF JANUARY TWENTY NINETEEN
THERE WERE OVER THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND UNIQUE STUDENTS SERVE
THERE ARE ON CAMPUS FOOD PANTRY.
AND A MAJORITY OF CAMPUSES OFFER
MEALS THROUGH MEAL SHARING OUR
MEAL VOUCHER PROGRAMS DURING
THAT SAME PERIOD CLOSE TO FORTY
FOUR HUNDRED MEALS WERE DONATED.
AND FIVE HUNDRED UNIQUE STUDENTS
RECEIVED A DONATED MAIL. FOR
GROWTH MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF
OUR CAMPUSES OFFER ON CAMPUS
EMERGENCY HOUSING OR VOUCHERS
FOR OFF CAMPUS HOUSING.
SEVERAL CAMPUSES PROVIDE
STUDENTS FACING HOUSING A FACING
A HOUSING EMERGENCY WITH HOTEL
VOUCHERS TO PROVIDE SHORT TERM
RELIEF AND THE CAMPUS WILL SERVE
AS A COSIGNER OUR LEASE
AGREEMENTS TO HELP STUDENTS
TRANSITION INTO LONG TERM
HOUSING. ONE OF THE BEST
PRACTICES WE'VE SEEN USED TO
ADDRESS STUDENTS SECURITY HAS
BEEN TO CONNECT STUDENTS TO CAL
FRONTS WE'VE ESTABLISHED CAL
FRESH AT THE PILLAR OF OUR BASIC
NEEDS WORK BY SCALING UP SYSTEM
WIDE.
WE'RE PROUD THAT IN THE CSU WE
HAVE CHICO STATE WHICH IS THE
LEAD.
ORGANIZATION FOR TRAINING AND
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR ALL COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES DOING CAL FRESH OUT
REGION APPLICATION ASSISTANCE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WHEN THE FIRST
CAL FRESH CONTRACT WITH SIGN
CHICO ONLY WORKED WITH TEN CSU
CAMPUSES TOTAL.
NOW CHICO STATE WILL BE WORKING
WITH FORTY TWO CAMPUSES
STATEWIDE INCLUDING NINETEEN CSU
CAMPUSES.
OUR PARTNERSHIP HAVE ALSO
EXPANDED SIGNIFICANTLY THEY'RE
CLOSE TO EIGHTY UNIQUE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT OUR
CAMPUSES WORK WITH.
NOT TO MENTION OUR CLOSE TIES
WITH OTHER SISTER HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHER EDUCATION BASIC NEEDS
ALLIANCE IS A COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE CSU UC AND CTC
SYSTEM.
WITH VARIOUS STAKEHOLDER
PARTICIPATION THE CSU
UNDERSTANDS THAT BASIC NEEDS IS
A PART OF A LARGER ISSUE THAT
GOES BEYOND OUR CAMPUS WALLS.
AND BECAUSE OF THIS WE NEED TO
CONNECT WITH PARTNERS THAT HAVE
EXPERTISE AND RESOURCES THAT CAN
BENEFIT OUR STUDENTS.
AND FINALLY FOR SINCE THEY IN
ABILITY ONE EXAMPLE WE ARE HAPPY
TO REPORT ON IS THE ADDITION. TO
OUR CALVET DATE APPLY
APPLICATION STARTING IN FALL
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE ADDED A
QUESTION TO OUR CALVET APPLY
APPLICATION.
WHICH IS THE APPLICATION FOR ALL
FIRST TIME STUDENTS ASKING IF
THEY WERE INTERESTED IN LEARNING
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT CAL FRESH.
JUST A SINGLE QUESTION WILL HELP
ESTABLISH WHAT STUDENTS ARE
INTERESTED IN POSSIBLY ELIGIBLE
FOR CALTRANS.
SINCE SEPTEMBER WE'VE HAD OVER A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS CHECK THAT YES BOX
WHICH IS A LITTLE OVER HALF OF
ALL STUDENTS THAT HAVE APPLIED
FOR CAP THE FOURTH YES YOU.
THIS IS SCALABLE CHANGE WILL
ALLOW CAMPUSES TO SEE WHICH
STUDENTS ARE INTERESTED AND
LIKELY ELIGIBLE AND WILL ALLOW
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE.
TARGETED OUR REACH.
THE CURRENT FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME FINDING BUDGET
ASK IT'S FOR EXPANDING OUR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL SUPPORT
AGENCIES AS WELL AS SUPPORTING
HOLISTIC WELL BEING.
INCLUDING ME ENHANCEMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND HEALTH
PROMOTION PROGRAMS ON CAMPUS A
FEW EXAMPLES OF THIS INCLUDE
INTEGRATING A WELLBEING
TECHNOLOGY PROP PLATFORM.
PILOT TESTING SEVERAL HOUSING
STRATEGIES CONNECTING WITH
CONTINUUM OF CARE AGENCIES
STATEWIDE.
ONGOING ASSESSMENT OF CURRENT
PROGRAMS AND STRATEGIES TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE BEST WAYS
TO ENGAGE STUDENTS.
WE KNOW THAT THERE IS MUCH WORK
TO BE DONE BUT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL LATE LEGISLATIVE
ALLIES TO HELP US ENSURE THAT
ALL STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM [inaudible]
MISTER GELLER [inaudible]
TINA [inaudible]
HELLO MY YOU KNOW.
YOUR POINT ABOUT -- NOT HAVING
THE CONTINUING FUNDING FOR CS
YOU ARE DOING THAT FOR YOU SEE.
ME I THINK THERE'S JUST AS MUCH
JUSTIFICATION. FOR DOING THAT
THE CSU A PROBLEM I WOULD ARGUE
MORE -- SO I MEAN I THINK THAT'S
DEFINITELY IN THE MAY BE THE AS
HE SAID THE REFORMS TO THE CAL
GRANT BE -- MIGHT BE A WAY.
TO YOU HELP ADDRESS THAT ISSUE --
SO.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GUYS HAD ANY
RESPONSE TO THAT BUT GO AHEAD.
I DO -- SO WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE IS
THEY'VE -- THEY'VE RECEIVED
REQUESTS BOTH FROM YOU SEE AND
FROM C. ISSUE ARE YOU UNIQUE --
REQUESTS HAVE BEEN DIFFERENT.
SO UC'S WAS A ONE AS AN ONGOING
REQUEST OURS IS A ONE TIME.
REQUEST AND THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS SUPPORTED THAT BY INCLUDING
THOSE ELEMENTS IN OUR RESPECTIVE
BUDGETS.
I THINK IN TERMS OF THE ON GOING
NOTION OF THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE WOULD NEED TO TAKE BACK
TO OUR BOARD AND OUR LEADERSHIP.
TO DETERMINE WHETHER WE WANTED
TO MAKE IT A AN ONGOING SORT OF
ENDEAVOR AT THIS POINT TIME WE
FEEL LIKE -- AS AS DR BEVERLY
WAS TALKING ABOUT.
ESTABLISHING THOSE PARTNERSHIPS --
REQUIRES ONE TIME MONIES AND WE
FEEL THAT THAT'S PROBABLY THE
THE THE BEST USE OF ONE TIME
MONIES THERE I THINK WHEN IT
COMES TO ONGOING FUNDING.
WE PREFER THAT MOST OF OUR ON
GOING FUNDING GOES -- TO MORE OF
THAT THE CORE MISSION -- FOCUSED
ELEMENTS OF THE UNIVERSITY.
ENROLLMENT GRAD INITIATIVE
COMPENSATION THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS.
ALL RIGHT SO -- FORGIVE ME IF I
MISSED THIS BUT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT ONE TIME FUNDING YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
THE THOSE THOSE DOLLARS -- BEING
INTENDED TO EXPAND THE
PARTNERSHIPS TO ME WHAT WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN WHEN THOSE ONE TIME
FUNDS RUN OUT.
SO THE REASON WE WANT TO CONNECT
WITH -- AGENCIES IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT HAVE A TRADITION
OF WORKING WITH THESE TYPES OF
POPULATIONS IS SO THAT.
THEY'RE USED TO RECEIVING ONE
TIME DOLLARS AND MAKING THEM
STRETCH AND THEY USUALLY THEY'LL
HAVE SOMEONE WHO'S ALREADY --
WORKING IN THIS AREA THAT HAS
EXPERTISE IN REACHING OUT -- THE
ISSUE WITH ONE TIME FINDING IS
THAT OUR CAMPUSES ARE NOT I'M
PRONE TO HIRE ON FOLKS TO HELP
WITH THIS.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE FUNDING RUNS
OUT THEY'RE NOT YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS TO THAT POSITION SO WHAT
WE'RE HOPING IS THAT BY FINDING
THESE COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
THAT THEY WOULD BE ABLETO
CONTINUE THIS PARTNERSHIP BEYOND
THE DOLLARS.
I'M AND THEN WORK WITH OUR
CAMPUSES TO EITHER GO AFTER
ADDITIONAL GRANT FUNDING --
EXTERNALLY OR LOOK FOR OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FUNDING IN THE
FUTURE OKAY SO THIS WOULD BE
KIND OF LIKE.
TO KICK START SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS.
AND AND AND THAT SEEMS LIKE A
VERY -- EFFICIENT -- WAY OF
STRETCHING THE IMPACT OF OF OF
STATE DOLLARS -- SO IT -- THE
THE LA -- MENTION TO OR AS
SUGGESTED SOME METRICS -- FOR
EVALUATING THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THIS A ONE TIME -- DOLLARS WHAT
WOULD BE THE BASIC PARAMETERS OF
THE METRICS YOU BE LOOKING.
I'D DEFINITELY LOOKING AT THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT ARE
BEING SERVED BY THESE
ORGANIZATIONS -- WITH THE FOLLOW
FOLLOW UP IS.
I'M ALSO LOOKING AT SOME
ACADEMIC SUCCESS INDICATORS AND
CROSS REFERENCING KNOWS AND
LOOKING AT THE CORRELATION
BETWEEN THOSE AND SOME OF THESE.
ACT BOB OUT OF CLASSROOM SUPPORT --
I THINK REALLY TRYING TO MEASURE
THE IMPACT OF SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS HAS BEEN A LITTLE BIT
MORE CHALLENGING -- SO WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW BEST TO
SHOW THE IMPACT OF THESE
PROGRAMS ON SOME OF THOSE
INTERRED INDICATORS.
I GUESS ADD.
TO YOUR ACCOUNT FOR USING
CORPORATION IT INTO.
A REGULAR SURVEY THE DAY CONDUCT
FOR STUDENTS QUESTIONS
PERTAINING -- TO HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS AND SO THAT THAT'S
GOING TO GIVE THEM THE ABILITY
OVER TIME TO SEE IF.
THINGS ARE CHANGING GETTING
BETTER FOR STUDENTS WHAT WHAT
THE IMPACT IS SET SOMETHING TO
CONSIDER FOR CSU THEY SAY
MENTIONED THEY DID A PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE SURVEY --
THROUGHOUT TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN I KNOW SEE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO DO MORE.
OF THE SAME AND AND SOMETHING --
MORE SURVEYS LIKE THAT NOT THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL.
NOT JUST FOR FOR CSU BUT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ASSESS THE IMPACT
OF THESE DOLLARS [inaudible]
OKAY.
IN AND THEN YOU KNOW LIKE I HAVE
A A GENERAL QUESTION I WE WE'VE
BEEN.
SPENDING A LOT OF TIME IN THIS --
SUBCOMMITTEE TALKING ABOUT --
YOU KNOW HOW THE IN THE HOUSING
AND AND AND FOOD AND SECURITY
ISSUES THAT HAVE BECOME YOU KNOW.
DRAMATICALLY -- MUCH MORE
PROMINENT -- AND AND AND I KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW SO MUCH OF THAT IS
IS [inaudible]
DRIVEN BY.
THE THE OVERALL COST OF HOUSING
THE OVERALL COST OF LIVING
ESPECIALLY IN OUR OUR CAMPUS IS
LOCATED IN OUR OUR COASTAL AREAS.
HOW DO I -- HOW DO YOU RESPOND --
TO TO YOU KNOW.
MY MY CONSTITUENTS THAT TALK
ABOUT -- YOU KNOW.
BACK IN BACK IN THEIR DAY WHEN
THEY WHEN THEY ATTEND COLLEGE
YOU KNOW THEY IS THEY THEY THEY
WERE THEY WERE THEY WERE JUST
HAPPY TO TO HAVE SOME OF THE
TUITION COVERED THAT -- YOU KNOW
THAT NOW YOU CAN NOW THE STATE --
IS IS GETTING INTO -- AND AND TO
PROVIDE A MORE HOUSING AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE.
IT WILL WHAT WHAT HAS CHANGED --
TO IN IN IT YOU KNOW FOR FROM
THESE PREVIOUS GENERATIONS.
WHY -- I MEAN I WOULD SAY THAT
THAT THE OUR CAMPUSES ARE
MICROCOSM OF LARGER SOCIETY.
AND THAT -- AS COSTS HAVE RISEN
THEY HAVEN'T JUST WITHIN FOR
OUTSIDE OF THE CAMPUS THEY'VE
WRITTEN FOR STUDENTS THAT ARE ON
CAMPUS AS WELL.
ADD AS MUCH AS WE ARE PROVIDING
SUPPORTS THOSE ACADEMIC SUPPORTS
OUR STUDENTS TO BE SUCCESSFUL WE
ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT OUT OF
CLASSROOM SUPPORTS AS WELL -- IT
AND YOU KNOW AS AS WE SEE THAT
OUR STUDENT POPULATION INVOLVING
WE TO HAVE TO A FAULT -- WITH
THE TYPES OF SUPPORTS THAT WORKS
FOR PROVIDING STUDENTS SO I JUST
THINK YOU KNOW THE COST OF
LIVING THE COSTS OF ATTENDING
SCHOOL OF THE COST ALL OF THAT
HAS.
GONE UP NO WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
THAT ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
STAD -- TAKE.
YOUR ANTENNAE SO.
ON TO SOMETHING YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE STUDENTS FROM FROM DECADES
AGO IT.
IT IS DIFFERENT TO IN TERMS OF
STUDENTS WHO ATTENDED FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS DECADES AGO VERSUS
TODAY WHICH IS A GOOD THING YOU
HAVE -- MORE -- ACCESS --
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS FROM LOWER
INCOMES -- SO LACK THERE COULD
BE SOMETHING THERE.
ANOTHER SOMETHING INTERESTING OF
FROM MY MENTIONED UC CONDUCTS A
SURVEYS OF THEIR STUDENTS AND
WHAT THEY FOUND WAS THAT. ONE
QUARTER OF STUDENTS WHO SAID
THERE.
CAME FROM FAMILIES EARNING A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR MORE.
EXPERIENCED SOME FOOD AND
SECURITY SO QUARTER AND AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S SOMEWHAT
OF A PUZZLE. FOR US IS SOMETHING
WE WANT TO UNDERSTAND BETTER IS
IT THE THE FACT THAT IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE HIGH HOUSING
HOUSING COSTS A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS JUST DOESN'T.
GO AS FAR AS AS IT DOES
ELSEWHERE MAYBE THE PARENTS
AREN'T ABLE TO HELP THE STUDENTS
WITH THE EXPECTED FAMILY
CONTRIBUTION.
COULD BE AN ISSUE OF OF
UNUSUALLY HIGH COSTS FOR CERTAIN
STUDENTS AS WELL YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY HAVE THEY HAVE UNIQUE
CONDITIONS SO THERE'S THERE'S
THERE'S SOME LOT OF THINGS DONE
PACKED THERE AND AND AND TRY TO
UNDERSTAND BETTER. TO GET IT
KIND OF THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM
ESPECIALLY FOR STUDENTS AGAIN
FROM HIGHER INCOME MORE AFFLUENT
FAMILIES THAT HER REPORTING
THEY'RE HAVING TROUBLE AS WELL.
AND TO SEE IF YOU HAVE ANY --
ANY ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT WHY
WHY THE MIDDLE AND AND AND
HIGHER INCOME -- STUDENTS ARE
ALSO WE DID NOT ON OUR LAST
COMPREHENSIVE STUDY WE DID NOT
ASK THAT QUESTION SPECIFICALLY
BUT WE ANECDOTALLY FROM OUR
VISITS TO THE FOOD PANTRY.
THE FOLKS THAT ARE WORKING THERE
ARE THING MORE MINUTE.
STUDENTS THAT COME FROM
TRADITIONALLY MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES THAT ARE ACCESSING
SERVICES.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MOVING ON THEN TO ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN PROJECT REBOUND.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT PROJECT REBOUND WHICH IS
AN EXISTING PROGRAM OFFERED AT
NINE CSU CAMPUSES. TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
SEEKING ADMISSION TO THE
UNIVERSITY OR ARE CURRENTLY
ATTENDING ONE OF US
PARTICIPATING CSU CAMPUSES.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT HELLO THOUGH THERE IS
LIMITED DATA BASED ON A RECENT
SURVEY OF CAMPUSES BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE GRADUATES OF
PROJECT REBOUND APPEAR TO HAVE.
STRONG ACADEMIC AND EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES AND GIVEN THE STATE'S
INTEREST IN REHABILITATING
OFFENDERS THE LEGISLATURE MAY
AGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR THAT
SERVING THIS GROUP OF STUDENTS
IS A HIGH PRIORITY.
IF SO -- THOUGH THE AMOUNT
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING IS IS QUITE
SMALL REALISTICALLY IT'S ONLY
ENOUGH TO FIND.
A COUPLE OF STAFF AND SO RATHER
THAN PROVIDE THIS AMOUNT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ENCOURAGE CSU
TO LEVERAGE A MUCH LARGER POT OF
MONEY -- THAT FUNDS RECEIVED
FROM THE STATE THROUGH THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE IN USING
GRADUATION INITIATIVE FUNDS FOR
FORMALLY INCARCERATED STUDENTS
WOULD BE ENTIRELY CONSISTENT
WITH CAMPUSES CURRENT PRACTICES
OF USING THESE MONIES. TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT SERVICES TO
OTHER AT RISK STUDENTS SUCH AS
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS AND OTHER STUDENTS WITH
HIS FROM HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED BACKGROUNDS.
WITH US RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE ENCOURAGE CSU TO
PLACE A HIGH PRIORITY ON USING
GRADUATION INITIATIVE FUNDS TO
SUPPORT PROJECT REBOUND THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE.
HEARING ABOUT SOME ONE TIME
GRANTS THAT ARE ABOUT TO EXPIRE --
SO THE TIMING IS IS IMPORTANT
AND A LEGISLATURE -- MAY ALSO
WANT TO BEGIN REQUIRING THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO REPORT
REGULARLY ON PROJECT REBOUND ON
INFORMATION SUCH AS IN ROMANCE
STUDENT OUTCOMES IN SCHOOL AS
WELL AS ABILITY TO GET A JOB AND
AND STAY OUT OF STAY OUT OF
PRISON OR JAIL.
THANK YOU.
YES YEAH.
A GOOD MORNING -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN OUR HONORABLE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DOCTOR BRADY HEINER -- I'M A
PROFESSOR OF PHILOSOPHY -- AND
THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF PROJECT REBOUND AT
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY FULLER.
TEN I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE OF THE CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY PROJECT REBOUND
CONSORTIUM -- SO I ADDRESS YOU
TODAY AS A REPRESENTATIVE -- FOR
NINE CAMPUS PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING
THE NEW SEVEN MINISTRATION FOR
INCLUDING AN ONGOING ALLOCATION
FOR PROJECT REBOUND IN THE
COMING YEARS BUDGET.
I ALSO WISH TO THANK THE MEMBERS
OF THIS GROUP.
COMMITTEE FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW WORDS
ABOUT OUR WORK -- AND WHY WHILE --
VERY HELPFUL THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ALLOCATION
FALLS SHORT OF THE SUPPORT
NEEDED TO SUSTAIN AND TO SCALE
ARE ARE PROVEN MODEL OF SUCCESS --
THE MISSION A PROJECT REBOUND IS
TO SUPPORT THE HIGHER EDUCATION
AND SUCCESSFUL REINTEGRATION OF
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE.
THE CORNERSTONE OF OUR
PHILOSOPHY IS THAT THE
LEADERSHIP AND MENTORSHIP OF
OTHER FORMERLY INCARCERATED
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS AND
GRADUATES.
FOSTERS A SENSE OF BELONGING AND
ACHIEVEMENT AMONG FORMALLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS THAT
MAXIMIZES THEIR CHANCES OF
SUCCESS.
THIS IS WHY WE STAFF OUR ON
CAMPUS PROGRAMS WITH TRAINED
PROFESSIONALS WHO LIKE OUR
STUDENTS HAVE EXPERIENCED
INCARCERATION.
AND WHO EXEMPLIFY THE SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION TOWARD WHICH OUR
STUDENTS ASPIRE.
PROJECT REBOUND WAS FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY BY
SOCIOLOGY PROFESSOR JOHN -- WHEN?
AFTER SERVING FIVE YEARS IN
STATE PRISON FOR ARMED ROBBERY --
WHEN EARNED A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
FROM UCLA A PHD FROM UC BERKELEY
AND ESTABLISH PROJECT REBOUND AS
A PATHWAY TO MATRICULATE THE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED INTO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY?
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
PROJECT REBOUND STUDENTS EARNED
A BACHELOR'S OR MASTER'S DEGREE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO STATE BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE AND TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN THROUGH THE
OPPORTUNITY INSTITUTES RENEWING
AND COMMUNITIES INITIATIVE. NINE
CSU CAMPUSES CLLABORATED TO
PILOT THE PROJECT REBOUND
CONSORTIUM MODELED AFTER THE
ORIGINAL PROGRAM AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE.
THE PROJECT REBOUND CONSORTIUM
CURRENTLY INCLUDES PROGRAMS AT
CAMPUSES IN BAKERSFIELD FRESNO
FULLER TEN LOS ANGELES POMONA
SACRAMENTO SAN BERNARDINO SAN
DIEGO AND SAN FRANCISCO.
THESE PROGRAMS NOW PROVIDE A
STATEWIDE NETWORK OF SUPPORT FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS TO ASSIST THEM TO
ESTABLISH EDUCATIONAL PLANS
APPLY FOR ADMISSION AND
FINANCIAL AID.
SOCIALLY REINTEGRATE AND
ULTIMATELY GRADUATE FROM THE CSU.
MOST OF ALL PROJECT REBOUND
OFFERS A COMMUNITY OF SUPPORT TO
STUDENTS WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
THE TRAUMAS OF PRISON AND NOW
FACE A MULTITUDE OF SOCIAL
BARRIERS RELATED TO HOUSING.
EMPLOYMENT TRANSPORTATION FOOD
AND COMPUTER LITERACY BARRIERS
THAT HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
DERAIL THEIR LIVES AND LEAD TO
RE ARREST.
OUR PROGRAMS WORK.
THE STUDENTS IN OUR PROGRAMS DO
NOT RETURN TO PRISON.
AFTER THREE YEARS OF OPERATION
THE PROJECT REBOUND CONSORTIUM
HAS IS 0% RECIDIVISM RATE.
BY COMPARISON THE THREE YEAR
RECIDIVISM RATE IN CALIFORNIA IS
50%.
BUT RECIDIVISM IS JUST A MINIMAL
METRIC OF OUR STUDENT SUCCESS
OUR STUDENTS NOT ONLY DESIST
FROM CRIME.
THEY NOT ONLY PERSISTENT SCHOOL
[inaudible]
THEY EXCEL.
PROJECT REBOUND REDUCES
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AMONG STUDENTS
FROM HISTORICALLY UNDER SERVED
AND EDUCATIONALLY DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS.
OUR STUDENTS 60% OF WHOM ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN OR LATINO.
HAVE EARNED AN OVERALL GRADE
POINT AVERAGE OF THREE POINT NO
NEARLY EVERY SEMESTER.
AT CAL STATE FULLERTON TO
ADDRESS THE HIGH RATES OF
HOUSING AND SECURITY AMONG OUR
RE ENTERING STUDENTS.
PROJECT REBOUND HAS PILOTED THE
FIRST REENTRY HOUSING INITIATIVE
FOR FORMERLY INCARCERATED
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS IN THE
NATION.
AND AMONG OUR STUDENTS WHO
RECEIVE HOUSING SUPPORT THE
OVERALL GRADE POINT AVERAGE IS
THREE POINT.
SEVEN THROUGHOUT THE CONSORTIUM
PROJECT REBOUND STUDENTS HAVE
SECURED SCHOLARSHIPS VOLUNTEERED
FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND LANDED
INTERNSHIPS AND JOBS IN THEIR
FIELDS.
BY THE END OF NEXT MONTH THE
PROJECT REBOUND CONSORTIUM WILL
HAVE GRADUATED OVER TWO HUNDRED
STUDENTS IN JUST THREE YEARS.
DURING WHICH TIME THE ENROLLMENT
IN OUR PROGRAMS HAS MORE THAN
DOUBLED. 87% OF PROJECT REBOUND
GRADUATES SECURE EMPLOYMENT OR
ENROLLED IN POST GRADUATE
PROGRAMS.
IN CONCLUSION LET ME SAY THAT
NOW IS THE CRITICAL TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO INVEST IN PROJECT
REBOUND.
IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR THE
PHILANTHROPIC SEED GRANT THAT
FUNDS THE GENERAL OPERATION OF
OUR PROGRAMS WILL CONCLUDE.
A HANDFUL OF OUR PROGRAMS WILL
BE FORCED TO SHUT THEIR DOORS IN
THE ABSENCE OF ALTERNATIVE
LONGITUDINALLY SUSTAINABLE FORMS
OF SUPPORT.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S ALLOCATION
WHILE HELPFUL STILL FALLS
SIGNIFICANTLY SHORT OF THE
SUPPORT NEEDED TO SUSTAIN WHAT
WE'VE BUILT.
AND MEET INCREASING DEMAND.
MISTER CHAIRMAN HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WE ASK
FOR YOUR INCREASED SUPPORT TO
ENABLE US TO SUSTAIN AND SCALE
ARE PROVEN MODEL OF SUCCESS. TO
BUILD SAFER COMMUNITIES AND A
STRONGER ECONOMY FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU THAT.
TO THOSE ARE -- IMPRESSIVE
NUMBERS AND I AM -- YOU KNOW I A
I THINK THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT --
SHOULD BE.
A FURTHER HIGHLIGHTED AND AND
AND SHARED AS A SUCCESS STORY --
I WANTED -- TO JUST SAYS SOME --
BASIC QUESTIONS SO -- ART.
DID YOU HAVE NUMBERS IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW THE THE IT WITH THE V.
ENROLLED -- STUDENTS AND AND
PROJECT REBOUND A YOU KNOW
WHETHER THEY HAVE -- FELONY
CONVICTIONS OR MISDEMEANOR
CONVICTIONS ADMITTED THAT THE
NATURE OF THE GRAVITY OF THEIR
THEIR PRIOR OFFENSES -- SO -- TO
THIS POINT WE HAVEN'T HAD THE
FUNDING TO TO CONDUCT ROBUST.
ASSESSMENT PROGRAM EVALUATION --
BUT WE DO KNOW -- THAT THE
STUDENTS IN OUR PROGRAM.
RANGE IN TERMS OF CONVICTION
HISTORIES FROM -- HAVING SERVICE
A FEW WEEKS IN COUNTY JAIL TO
SERVING TWENTY THREE YEARS IN
STATE PRISON OKAY.
AND WE WE HAVE NO.
NON ACADEMIC SCREENING CRITERIA --
FOR THE ADMISSION SINCE OUR
PROGRAM ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
BUT MAIN [inaudible]
GAIL.
AND HAVING.
TO WORKED AS A PROSECUTOR MY
PREVIOUS LIFE I MEAN I I KNOW
THAT INCARCERATION CAN BE AND
ANYTHING FROM.
SPENDING AYE -- IN A FEW NIGHTS
IN JAIL FOR DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF ALCOHOL.
TO OBVIOUSLY MUCH MORE SERIOUS
CRIMES BUT DID YOU DO YOU HAVE
ANY.
ANY -- YOU KNOW FURTHER -- YEAH
I DATA TO TO GIVE ME A GREATER
SENSE OF APPRECIATION FOR THE
THE STUDENT POPULATION THERE SIR.
WELL I CAN TELL YOU A BIT ABOUT
THE DEMOGRAPHICS -- OF OUR
STUDENT POPULATION -- SO 25% ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN 35% -- ARE
LATINO.
WE HAVE -- AT CAL STATE
FULLERTON -- WE'VE -- ASKED
STUDENTS -- FURTHER QUESTIONS
ABOUT ABOUT THEIR STATUS -- AND
AS IS ANNA GO TO GO EAT I THINK
REPRESENTATIVE ACROSS THE THE
CONSORTIUM -- ABOUT 60% OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS -- 40% OF OUR
STUDENTS HAVE CHILDREN UNDER THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN I I WILL SAY
THAT -- WELL I DON'T HAVE DATA --
TO TELL YOU ABOUT -- BREAKDOWNS
OF CONDITION HISTORIES -- I WILL
SAY THAT -- THE PRESENCE AND
PARTICIPATION OF STUDENTS -- WHO?
WERE FORMER LIFERS -- WHO DO WHO
DO WHO DO DID A LOT OF TIME HAS
BEEN?
REALLY SENSUAL -- THOSE ARE
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY WHO
REALLY SERVE AS THE GLUE -- AND
OFTEN TAKE ON ROLES WITH SOME OF
THE YOUNGER MEMBERS OF YET ROLES
OF MENTORSHIP WHICH IS REALLY AT
THE CENTER OF OUR OUR PHILOSOPHY
CREATING OF A MENTORSHIP
FEEDBACK LOOP -- WHERE --
FORMALLY INCARCERATED --
STUDENTS AND GRADUATES WHO HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION CAN CAN
IN TURN AROUND -- AND SUPPORT
FOLKS -- COMING OUT AND HELP
FOLKS NAVIGATE THE THE THE CSU --
WHICH AS AS YOU WELL KNOW CSU
CAMPUSES THERE'S OUR SMALL
CITIES -- AND SEE IF YOU
CLASSROOMS ARE MICROCOSM RIGHT --
OF OF OF THE CIVIC MAFIC
MICROCOSM THAN THEIR THEIR
SPACES -- WHERE OUR STUDENTS CAN --
ROOM REALLY BEGIN TO RIP
SOCIALLY REINTEGRATE -- SO --
BUT WHY DON'T HAVE DATA WHAT THE
THE INCREASE REQUEST -- THAT
WERE MAKING WOULD INCLUDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US -- TO TO TO
CONDUCT A ROBUST ASSESSMENT.
OKAY YEAH I AGAIN.
I WAS LIKE A GREAT PROGRAM I I
JUST THINK THAT TO TO FURTHER
HIGHLIGHTING SHOWCASE THE
PROGRAM MAYBE IT WOULD BE --
YOU'D BE GOOD TO GET A BETTER
SENSE AS TO THE THE THE THE THE
THE THE THE NATURE -- OF THAT
THE PRIOR CRIMINAL HISTORY OF OF
THE THE STUDENTS TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS PROGRAM.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO DO THAT
ASSESSMENT THANK YOU.
SO THERE ARE MORE TO CHEAT YOU
OUT I ASKED IF I WANTED.
TO SAY ANYTHING YES HI PASSED
BEFORE BY LIKE TO JUMP
ANNOUNCEMENT COULD -- SO ONE ONE
THING THAT -- HAVE TO STIPULATE
THIS IS A FANTASTIC PROGRAM
RIGHT TO IT TO SEE PEOPLE TURN
THEIR LIVES AROUND IS A
FANTASTIC ACHIEVEMENT AND KUDOS
TO ALL OF OUR FOLKS WHO RUN
PROJECT REBOUND.
I THINK THE ONE THING TO KEEP IN
MIND -- WHEN IT COMES DOWN -- TO
FUNDING THE UNIVERSITY IS THAT --
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PRESSURES
AND THERE'S A LOT OF NEED OUT
THERE RIGHT PROJECT REBOUND IS
ONE OF MANY GREAT PROGRAMS IS
PROGRAMS FOR VETS AND DREAMERS
AND ALL KINDS OF OTHER.
SUBGROUPS.
THE THE THE THE CHALLENGE THAT
WE HAVE IS A SYSTEM IS IS IF WE
END UP HAVING A SITUATION WHERE
THE LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR
DECIDE -- TO ADD ADDITIONAL
SPECIAL PREPARATIONS FOR CERTAIN
THINGS.
THAT DOES CIRCUMVENT THE
PRIORITIES THAT THE PRESIDENT'S%
AND THE LEADERS OF THE CAMPUSES
HAVE ALREADY ESTABLISHED.
CERTAINLY LET'S TALK ABOUT
PROJECT REBOUND AS AN EXAMPLE.
WE HAVE THE LET'S SAVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE YOU SUGGESTING THAT WE
USE SOME OF THAT THAT WE THAT
THE STATE TAKE PART OF THE GRAD
MISSION OF FUNDING AND MAYBE
PERHAPS I DON'T KNOW HOW
SPECIFIC BUT PERHAPS YOUR MARK
FUNDING FROM THE GRAD INITIATIVE
FOR PROJECT REBOUND.
OKAY THAT DOES WHAT THAT ENDS UP
DOING IS IS THAT THAT KIND OF
UNDERMINES OUR PHILOSOPHY A
SYSTEM WIDE LEVEL IS TO ALLOCATE
AS MUCH FUNDING AS WE CAN. TO
OUR CAMPUSES WITH THEM HAVING
THE ON THE ON THE GROUND --
EXPERIENCE NO WHERE TO ALLOCATE
THOSE FUNDING IT WHERE THAT BUT
I NEED TO GO AND WHAT THIS PARTY
LEVELS ARE.
COULD CERTAINLY WILL BE THAT IF
THIS YEAR'S GRADUATION ISSUE OF
FUNDING IS FULLY FUNDED.
BRADY OVER HERE TO GET TWO
MILLION DOLLARS SYSTEM WIDE
BECAUSE OF THE DISTANCE THE
DISTINCTIVE MAYBE THE EXPANSION
OF SO I WANT.
TO HOPEFULLY PUT A KIND OF A BOX
AROUND HER ABOUT AROUND IT SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE THAT
DISTINCTION WHERE IT'S NEEDED
MOST -- AND CERTAINLY -- YOU'RE
MARKING FUNDING IN PARTICULAR
WAYS COULD END UP CREATING SOME
ADDICTED SICK UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SO I JUST WANTED TO
KIND OF THROW THAT OUT OKAY THE
COMMITTEE TOGETHER POINT WELL
TAKEN I THINK I I THINK IT'S A
COMMON THEME IN THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE THE THE BALANCING
BETWEEN A AND THE YOU.
KNOW GIVING FULL DISCRETION TO
OUR EDUCATORS VERSES THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTING FUNDING
FOR PRIORITIES.
BUT MAN THANK YOU. FOR FOR THE
COMMENT -- ANY ANYTHING FURTHER.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
SO -- ALL RIGHT I'D LIKE -- TO
AND NOW OPEN -- THE HEARING UP
FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS I ASK A NOW
ALL PUBLIC COMMENTS TO BE
LIMITED TO A MINUTE [inaudible]
GLAZER.
GO FORWARD AND STEP UP TO THE
MIKE
.
JUST LOOK AROUND.
THIS IS A WITH THE OKAY.
CAN WE DO AFTER YEAH.
OR DID YOU JUST WANT HAVE A
QUICK COMMENT.
A BEFORE WE START [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT OUT BEFORE WE GO UP
FURTHER WITH PUBLIC COMMENTS --
SOME OF OUR MEDINA I KNOW YOU
WANTED TO MAKE BUT PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
PROJECT ON A HURRIED OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE WHERE I WAS PRESENTING.
BECAUSE I WANTED TO SPEAK ON
ITEM -- SEVEN THE FULLERTON
PROJECT REBOUND.
AS SOMEONE WHO SPENT OF SEVERAL
YEARS [inaudible]
OF BOTH.
IN CORRECTIONS AND AS A TEACHER --
AT CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION FOR
WOMEN WHERE I WAS A TEACHER OF
ADULT EDUCATION. FOR TWO YEARS --
SO HAVING SPENT SOME TIME IN OUR
PRISON SYSTEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE PROBABLY NEVER SEEN SUCH
A MORE WORTHWHILE PROJECT.
THEN PROJECT REBOUND -- PROJECT
REBOUND ALLOWS FOR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED MEN AND WOMEN.
A TO GET A COLLEGE EDUCATION.
IN THE CSU SYSTEM.
A PROGRAM THAT IS SHOWN ITS
VIABILITY.
OF PROGRAM THAT HAS [inaudible]
ZERO RECIDIVISM.
I I I WOULD SAY AS I SIT HERE
THAT WHEN I WAS A TEACHER AT CI
W..
UNFORTUNATELY ONLY HAVING TAUGHT
THERE FOR TWO YEARS.
I SAW WOMEN LEAVE AND COME BACK.
IN MY TWO YEARS OF TEACHING
THEIR THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT HAS
ZERO RECIDIVISM.
AS A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER.
AS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRUSTEE.
I KNOW THE VALUE OF EDUCATION
THE EDUCATION.
CHANGES PEOPLE'S LIVES THIS
PROGRAM HAS DEMONSTRATED THAT IT
DOES THAT IT CHANGES PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
GIVES OPPORTUNITY.
THAT MEN AND WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN
IN PRISON DESERVE. TO CHANGE
THEIR LIVES TO BECOME
SUCCESSFULLY.
INTEGRATED INTO OUR SOCIETY I
THINK THAT IS THE GOAL OF OUR OF
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM.
AND SO I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THE THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT -- IS BEING ASKED
FOR AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT IS INCLUDED IN OUR BUDGET IT
IS MONEY WELL SPENT.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER -- COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE -- LET'S SAY
PROCEED WITH THE PUBLIC AND HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENTS GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS SEASONAL CANTON I'M THE
ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT -- FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FACT WHISTLES
ASIAN AND A PROFESSOR OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AT CAL STATE
SACRAMENTO -- CFA SUPPORTS THE
OVERALL FUNDING LEVELS FOR THE
CSU AND AND WE REQUEST THAT THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS BE
SET ASIDE TO HIRE NEW TENURE
TRACK FACULTY.
I HAS BEEN NOTED IN YOUR NOTES --
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN TENURE
TRACK FACULTY AND STUDENT
STUDENT UP LONGEVITY AS WELL AS
STUDENT SUCCESS IT'S BEEN WIDELY
DOCUMENTED -- WE NEED MORE
TENURE TRACK FACULTY.
IN THE CSU IF WE CAN GET THAT I
THINK WE CAN SHOW YOU.
ARE THE CSU CAN BE UP CAN BE
EVEN BETTER AT PROVIDING A THE
THE KINDS OF SERVICES TO
STUDENTS THAT THEY REQUIRE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING -- I AM CURRENTLY A
BECAUSE BECAUSE THEY POLLS AND
SOON I'M A SECOND YEAR AND I'M A
PUBLIC MINISTRATION AND
PUBLICIZE STUDENT -- I'M HERE
PART OF A CLASS OF JOURNEY AND
ADVOCACY WE ARE AS A DEPOSIT
ACADIA TO TEACHING STUDENTS HOW
TO GET INVOLVED IN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES BY MULE STATES AND
LIMóN MEMBERS AND SAY CENTERS --
WE GET WE ARE TAUGHT HOW TO GET
INVOLVED IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AT HOW THE SAY
FUNCTIONS -- DISCUSS CORPORATE
THE TRIP WAS SACRAMENTO WHICH IS
SUCH AN HONOR AND MANY STUDENTS
MYSELF INCLUDED HAD NEVER BEEN
TO SACRAMENTO.
IT'S IT'S SUCH A NOT HONORED CA
COMMITTEE WORK AND IT'S BETTER
TO AND FLUSHED NOT INSTEAD OF A
SCREEN OR BOTH COR THAT'S JUST
IT'S JUST SO MUCH BETTER SEE AND
HOW IT ACTUALLY WILL FUNCTIONS --
THE IT'S AMAZING HOW THESE
COMMITTEES JUST GO THROUGH AND
RETURN THRILLED -- BY SUPPORTING
THE CSU BUDGET YOU SUPPORT OUR
CLASSES AND SUPPORT OVER FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND
STUDENTS WHICH IS A GIANT.
PORTION AND IT'S PRETTY MUCH THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA MARGE SALLY
MUCH OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE IS
DATED EVEN IN VERY CLASSROOM
WHERE WE TAKE.
IT LEAKS HAVE LIAM WATER IT AND
MAKES IT PRETTY HARD TO FOCUS
WHEN YOU HAVE WATER DRIPPING ON
YOUR BACK -- SO AND THERE'S
HOLES THAT WERE STUDENTS IT'S
ONLY ONE ELEVATOR STUDENTS
ARRIVE LIKE.
AND IF YOU WANT STUDENTS WHO
WANT TO BE EDUCATED YOU WANT
THEM ALL THE TIME AND POPULOUS --
PLACER TRIED TRIED WRAP UP YOU
COME YEAH ON THE BECAUSE THEY
STILL A BECAUSE THEY SYSTEM IS
AN AMAZING SYSTEM WHICH IS A
GREAT INVESTMENT FOR CALIFORNIA.
BY CREATING VIGILS WHO PRODUCE
MORE AND MORE LIKELY TO GET
INVOLVED IN COMMUNITIES.
BY CONTINUE SUPPORTING THIS IS
BUDGET YOU CAN USE THE SUPPORT
EDUCATED STUDENTS WILL BECOME
THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA
CREATING MORE FIVE IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU AND WELCOME TO
SACRAMENTO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS VICKY BROWN I'M
PART OF THE TRAINING ADVOCACY
CLASS AND I'M A SENIOR ANIMATION
MAJOR IN COMPUTER SCIENCE MINOR
AT CAL STATE FULLERTON -- I
REMEMBER IN MY SOPHOMORE YEAR I
TOOK A TWO HUNDRED LEVEL INTRO
TO ANIMATION COURSE AND WAS
SHOCKED TO SEE THAT ONE THIRD OF
THE CLASS WAS FULL OF SENIORS
AND AND PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THEIR
FIFTY YEAR -- AND SO I ASKED
AROUND LIKE WONDERING WHY --
THEY'RE WAITING THIS LONG SIX
CLASSES BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT IN
OF COURSE SECTIONS OFFERED AND
THEY HAD BEEN TRYING MULTIPLE
TIMES TO TAKE THAT CLASS.
AND SO -- SUPPORTING THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE -- FOR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE ALLOWS US TO
HAVE MORE FULL TIME FACULTY AND
TENURE TRACK FACULTY AN EXPENSE
REPORT SERVICES AND INCREASE
COURSE OPPOSITE OFFERINGS --
TALENTED STUDENTS SHOULDN'T HAVE
TO WAIT FOREVER TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE THE COURSES THAT THEY NEED
TO GRADUATE ON TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU.
I AM A LITTLE SHORT -- MY NAME
IS MONICA MARTINEZ I'M ALSO PART
OF THE JOURNEY AND ADVOCACY
GLASS I'M A FOURTH YEAR CAL
STATE FULLERTON -- PLACE A MAJOR
AND A MINOR IN PHILOSOPHY.
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT -- MANY
MORE MORE FUNDING FOR LIVING
EXPENSES FOR STUDENTS I'M
CURRENTLY -- WORKING THREE JOBS
TRYING TO GET BY I DO RECEIVE
FINANCIAL AID BUT IT'S KIND OF
HARD -- ESPECIALLY WHEN I HAVE
TO PROLONG MY STAY AT CAL STATE
FULLERTON I COULD HAVE BEEN
GRADUATING THIS SPRING BUT
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO LIFE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THE EXPENSES.
BEING SO HIGH IN CALIFORNIA I
HAD TO PROLONG MY STATE SO IT
WOULD BE -- VERY IMPORTANT TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS MORE WITH
LIVING EXPENSES IS DUE TO THE
HIGH RENT COST -- GAS IS VERY
EXPENSIVE -- BEING A YOUNG
DRIVER IS ALSO VERY EXPENSIVE SO
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION THAT A
LOT OF STUDENTS COMMUTE TO THE
CAL STATES -- IT IS MORE
IMPORTANT -- TO FOCUS ON HOW
MUCH MONEY THEY HAVE TO PUT OUT
OF THE POCKET AND WORK MORE JOBS
AND SPEND LESS TIME ON CAMPUS
AND THIS TIME BEING INVOLVED.
AND CAREER PATHWAYS -- THAT CAN
HELP THEM IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING IS A MEMBER
MURATSUCHI MANY RODRIGUEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE EDUCATION TRUST
WEST YOU TO ADDRESS A FEW THINGS.
FIRST WE ASK THE LEGISLATURE TO
APPROVE THE FUNDING -- FOR
SERVICES FROM DOCUMENTED
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF AND
WE'RE GLAD THEY'RE TAKING A
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN THIS.
SECOND WE ASK THAT YOU APPROVE
THE FUNDING FOR FOOD HOUSING AND
SECURITY WAS TO GO A STEP
FURTHER IN MAKING THIS ONGOING --
NOT JUST A ONE TIME INVESTMENT.
THIRD REGARDING CSU GRAD
INITIATIVE WE ASK THAT YOU
APPROVE THIS FUNDING BUT ALSO
ASK THAT YOU DEMAND MORE AND
BETTER DATA REPORTING AND
TRANSPARENCY FOR THE OUTCOMES
FROM CAMPUSES IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR EXPEDITIOUSLY.
CLOSING GRADUATION GAS
MARGINALIZED STUDENTS UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENTS AND LASTLY
WE SUPPORT THE ENROLLMENT
INVESTMENT ABA WE ALSO ASK YOU
TO CONSIDER HOW THIS INVESTMENT
INTERSECTS WITH THE PROPOSAL THE
CSU BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
IS EXPLORING TO REQUIRE FOR THE
OF OF MATHEMATICS A QUANTITATIVE
REASONING WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME INEQUITIES WHEN IT COMES TO
A THROUGH G. ACCESS IN OUR CABLE
SYSTEM IN THIS PROPOSAL MIGHT
POTENTIALLY EXACERBATE SOME OF
THOSE INEQUITIES.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARTUCCI JAKE PARAMETER ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY I WANT TO
QUICKLY ECHO SOME OF THE
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES AT A TRUST WEST WE
ALSO SHARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FOURTH YEAR MATH REQUIREMENT
THAT'S BEING CONSIDERED -- BUT
WE DO SUPPORT INCREASED
INVESTMENT IN SERVING MORE
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
STUDENTS AT OUR CSU -- AND
LOOKING PAST THE FACT THAT THERE
MAY BE DECLINING COUNTS OF HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES BUT THERE ARE
INCREASING SHARES WERE
COMPLETING.
A THROUGH G. IN ARE ELIGIBLE TO
APPLY WE ALSO SHARE CONCERNED
ABOUT SOME OF THE DATA
LIMITATIONS WITH GRADUATION
INITIATIVE WE DO SUPPORT THAT
INVESTMENT AND AND CONTINUING TO
LOOK AT STUDENTS SUCCESSION
ANSWERS AT THE CSU.
BUT WE WOULD ALSO -- CALL
ATTENTION TO A RECOMMENDATION
PUT FORTH BY THE LA -- TO
EXPLORE HOW THE LEGISLATURE
COULD HELP TO FIND GOALS FOR
THIS AND REALLY THAT OPENS UP A
CONVERSATION AROUND THE STATE'S
LACK OF DEFINED GOALS AROUND
CLOSING OPPORTUNITY GAPS THAT IN
FACT.
ARE NOT ONLY PERSISTENT BUT
WIDENING YOUR AGENDA SHOWED AN
INCREASE IN THE GAP BETWEEN PAL
RECEIVING LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND NON TELL STUDENTS AND I
THINK THAT WARRANT SOME
CONVERSATION.
AND THEN FINALLY WE ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
UNDOCUMENTED HIGHER EDUCATION
COALITION ONCE YOU -- PUT ON UP
ON RECORD OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
LEGAL SERVICES FUNDING THAT SO
CRITICAL TIME DOCUMENTS STUDENTS
STAFF AND FACULTY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M A JIM HARPER I'M A
PART TIME FACULTY MEMBER ITS ACT
STATE.
I'M NOT SPEAKING FOR SOMEONE
SUCH AS MYSELF WHO USED TO TEACH
NIGHT CLASSES OFTEN ON WAS
WORKING FULL TIME.
OR NOW -- TEACH A DAY CLASS OR
TO OFTEN ON AT THE UNIVERSITY
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
ADJUNCT FACULTY SEEKING CAREERS.
IN PUBLIC SERVICE SEEKING
CAREERSAS FACULTY MEMBERS AT
THE UNIVERSITY.
THERE'S AT LEAST APPROXIMATELY
50% OR MORE OF THE IN PLOY EASE
AT THE C. ISSUE THAT ARE PART
TIME OR ADJUNCT FACULTY.
BUT MANY OF THEM ALSO THEY ARE
NOT REALLY PART TIME.
THEY'RE WORKING PRETTY MUCH FULL
TIME.
BUT THEY'RE NOT ON TENURE TRACK
JOBS THEY'LL HAVE THREE YEAR
CONTRACTS AND THEY DON'T HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO HAVE TENURE AND
THEY DON'T HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
RAISE.
THEIR SALARIES TO THE HIGHER
WAGES THAT A TENURE TRACK
FACULTY MEMBER WOULD HAVE THEY
DO HAVE BENEFITS NOW WHICH OF
COURSE IS VERY HELPFUL.
BUT I WOULD SUGGEST THAT THERE
BE AN EXAMINATION OF WOULD BE
THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL RATIO
BETWEEN TENURE TRACK FACULTY AND
ADJUNCT FACULTY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR THIS
TIME -- HI MY NAME IS NIKKI MET
THEM A LECTURE FOR SACRAMENTO
STATE I'M ALSO PART OF CFA THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP.
AND THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS THE OVERALL
FUNDING LEVELS FOR THE CSU
OBVIOUSLY HOWEVER SEE IF THEY
REQUEST HAT TWENTY MILLION
ABOUT BE SET ASIDE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH.
SPECIFICALLY TO REACH A RATIO OF
ONE F. T. COUNSELOR TO FIFTEEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS ON ALL CSU
CAMPUSES. EIGHTEEN MILLION WOULD
GO TO FOR HIRING NEW COUNSELORS
AND TWO MILLION FOR NEW
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING
TRACKING STUDENT SUICIDES AND
AND FOR CAMPUS MENTAL HEALTH
SURVEYS -- IT WITHIN THE FIRST
THREE OR FOUR WEEKS OF THIS PAST
SEMESTER OF ACTUALLY HAD THREE
OR FOUR STUDENTS COME TO ME
DIRECTLY WITH TALKS OF SUICIDE
IDEATION AND IT IS A GROWING
CROSS.
GOING GROWING CRISIS ACROSS THE
NATION AMERICAN PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION IS SAYING THAT THE
STATE OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
COLLEGE CAMPUSES IS INCREASING --
THE ACCREDITATION BODY FOR THE
COUNTING CENTERS INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF COUNSELING
SERVICES RECOMMENDS A RATIO OF
ONE THOUSAND TO ONE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS FOR EACH
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT COUNSELOR
ON EACH CAMPUS.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WAS ASKED TO SENATOR BUDGET
HEARING THIS YEAR BY SENATOR
LIVING WHY THE CS YOU DID NOT
RECEIVE FUNDING FOR MENTAL
HEALTH LIKE THE UC'S.
AND THE RESPONSES THAT THE UC
BUDGETREQUEST PRIORITIZED
FUNDING FOR MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS WHILE THE CSU DID NOT.
AND SO THE CSU MAY HAVE NOT
PRIORITIZE MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING
BUT WE ARE HERE TO ASK ABOUT
FUNDING BE PRIORITIZED TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS.
OF THE STUDENTS AND AND FACULTY
AS WELL AND STAFF THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS FOR THE CSU IS IS
STRONG IT'S REAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S ANDREW
WHEN I'M THE DIRECTOR PRIMARY
CONTACT STATE UNIVERSITY I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THREE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION.
ON AS SOMEBODY WHO WENT THROUGH
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM FORMING
CARS RATED IN PRO HOMELESS -- I
KNOW THE KITE TYPE OF THINGS
THAT CAN GO WRONG WITH TRYING TO
ACHIEVING EDUCATION ACTUALLY
FORMALLY CARTS RATED.
BECAUSE I ENDED UP EXPERIENCING
MANY OF THEM MYSELF -- INCLUDING --
ON THE VERGE OF HOMELESSNESS
WALL TUNING -- MIND IT GET MY
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE SO I URGE
YOU THE COMMITTEE TO GO AHEAD
AND SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING BY SHEPHERD
REPRESENTING THE CAL ASIAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE -- WE ARE
THE LARGEST STATEWIDE ETHNIC
CHAMBER IN THE STATE AND WE WORK
INSTANCE CONSISTENTLY TO CREATE
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES THROUGH
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT FOCUS ON
PROVIDING ACCESS EDUCATION.
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
BUSINESS SMALL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA JUST A QUICK
BACKGROUND AND AB I OWN
BUSINESSES GENERATE OVER A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE BILLION
IN ANNUAL REVENUE.
AND EMPLOYING OVER NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WORKERS IN THE STATE
AND WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
HOUSE -- BUDGET ALLOCATION FOR
CSU AND WE ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO MORE AND SO
THAT SEE IF YOU CAN MAINTAIN
MOMENTUM AN IMPROVING GRADUATION
RATE TO EXPAND ACCESS TO HELP ME
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE WORK FORCE
NEEDS.
AT BECAUSE THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
WE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CHRIS
**** AND I TEACH I'M A LECTURER
FACULTY AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY AND I'M ALSO HERE
WITH CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION.
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BUDGET ALLOCATION BUT I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
MENTAL HEALTH ON THE CSU
CAMPUSES.
WE HAVE THE MANY OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
MORNING.
HAVE IMPACTS ON MENTAL HEALTH.
AT SOME OF THE STATE WE HAVE A
LARGE PROBLEM HOMELESS STUDENTS.
WE'VE GOT LOTS OF STUDENTS
LIVING IN THEIR CARS I JUST AS
AN EXAMPLE ONE OF MY STUDENTS
FAIL TO GRADUATE ON TIME BECAUSE
HE LOST HIS HOUSING HE WAS
LIVING IN HIS CAR WHILE TRYING
O COMPLETE HIS DEGREE IN HIS
LAST SEMESTER.
ANYONE OF ACTUALLY HAVING TO EAT
FAILED CLASSES -- I'VE HAD I HAD
A STUDENT LAST SEMESTER WHO GOT
A GUN PULLED ON STUCK IN HER
FACE RIGHT BEFORE MY MID TERM I
NEEDED TO GET EMERGENCY MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT FOR THAT STUDENT
RIGHT THERE AT THAT MOMENT.
AND ON OUR OUR CAMPUS WE WORK AS
HARD AS WE CAN BUT IT'S VERY
CHALLENGING AND SO I THINK OF A
REALLY SERIOUS ABOUT SEEING SOME
IMPROVEMENT IN GRADUATION RATES
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THE FACT
THAT.
ISSUES LIKE HOMELESSNESS FOOD
AND SECURITY AMONG OUR STUDENTS
ALSO HAVE MENTAL HEALTH IMPACTS
AND ONE OF THE BEST WAYS THAT WE
CAN IMPROVE OUR GRADUATION RATE.
IS BY MAKING SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE THE MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT THAT OUR STUDENTS NEED
IN ADDITION TO THE TO THE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED
IN ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
SCHOOL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KEVIN WARE
PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY AT
SACRAMENTO STATE AND SECRETARY
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION.
I ALSO WANT TO SPEAK TO MENTAL
HEALTH AND THE NEED FOR
INCREASING INCREASE SUPPORT FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AND INCREASED
NUMBER OF COUNSELORS ON CAMPUS.
IN THE LAST ACADEMIC YEAR I HAD
THREE STUDENTS WHO CAME TO ME IN
OFFICE HOURS.
DIFFERENT STUDENTS TO EXPRESS
SUICIDAL IDEATION.
AFTER I PUT AWAY THE BOX OF
TISSUES THAT WE BOTH NEEDED -- I
A REFERRED THEM TO THE
COUNSELING CENTER TO GET
ASSISTANCE WHERE THEY WERE EACH
TOLD THAT AN APPOINTMENT WOULD
BE AVAILABLE IN FOUR WEEKS. FOUR
WEEKS FOR SOMEBODY EXPRESSING
SUICIDAL IDEATION IS DEEPLY
UNACCEPTABLE.
WE HAVE A RATIO ON MY CAMPUS OF
ONE FULL TIME COUNSELOR TO THREE
THOUSAND STUDENTS THAT'S TWICE
THE RECOMMENDED PERCENTAGE OF
EXCUSE ME THE RECOMMENDED RATIO --
WE NEED TO DO BETTER BY OUR
STUDENTS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME SO THAT I
WITH THE ADDRESS AND I AM A
POLITICAL SCIENCE STUDENTS
BECAUSE THEY CAMPUS I'M A FIFTY
YEAR AND I INTERNED FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION --
I A SUPPORT THE SERVICE REQUEST
FOR FUNDING TO MEET A PROPER
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELOR INCIDENT
RATIO ON ALL CSU CAMPUSES ON THE
AMERICAN PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION HAS STARTED USING
THE PHRASE GROWING CRISIS IN
REFERENCE TO A DECLINING MENTAL
HEALTH THE STUDENTS ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
THE INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION
FOR COUNSELORS COUNSELING
SERVICES THE ACCREDITATION BODY --
FOR COLLEGE COUNSELING CENTERS
CLAIMS THAT THERE SHOULD BE A
RATIO ONE COUNSELOR PRESS EVERY
THOUSAND TO FIFTEEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS AND YET WE SEE A FEEL
THERE TO MEET THOSE STANDARDS.
THROUGH THE ENTIRE CSU SYSTEM
THIS FAILURE IS EXEMPLIFIED
THREE DEATHS ON EVERYTHING --
CAMPUS THE DEATH OF SACRI BACK
AND SUCH BECAUSE THEY CAMPUS
ABOUT A YEAR AGO NO BETTER
EXEMPLIFIES THIS NEED.
OF HE'S JUMPED FROM A DEFINITE
BUILDING A BUILDING THAT I WAS
CURRENTLY IN TAKING A CLASS HE
JUMPED TO HIS DEATH I BELIEVE --
BUT HE IS NOT THE ONLY -- ONE
THERE HAS BEEN.
BENJAMIN KHOBAR TWENTY FOURTEEN
SAMANTHA LEWES IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN ACCORDING TO TASHA THE
NOT THE YEARS ARE IN TWENTY
ELEVEN AARON MATTHEW WITHIN
TWENTY SIXTEEN OF ALL THE POINTS
IN TWENTY TWELVE AND MANY MORE
LIVES THAT WE'VE LOST DUE TO
THIS GROWING MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS.
WE NEED ALL YOUR HELP ALL OF YOU
SO THAT STUDENTS ON THE CSU
CAMPUSES HAVE RESOURCES TO GET
HELP AND WE'RE IN NEED IN IT WE
PROACTIVE MEASURES AND NOT
REACTIVE MEASURES.
AND WE NEED THE MONEY THAT IS
ASK FOR SO THAT THESE MEASURES
BEGIN TO FORTIFY IN SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
STUDENTS BECAUSE WE ARE
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING -- COMMITTEE MEMBER
IS MY NAME IS ALLEY VESSEL
FALCON BAD AND I AM A FOURTH
YEAR AND STUDENT ADVOCACY IN A
UNIVERSITY.
AS A STUDENT THE CSU I FULLY
SUPPORT THE REQUESTED THAT ASIDE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION TO HIRE NEW
TENURE TRACK FACULTY INTO THE
CSU SYSTEM.
AS A FIRST GENERATION STUDENT IN
FUTURE EDUCATOR I HAVE BEEN
INSPIRED AND MENTORED BY SOME A
ME THE OF SOME OF YOUR MEETING
FACULTY WHO HAVE CONTINUOUSLY
FIELD MY HOPE. TO PURSUE A
GRADUATE DEGREE IN YOUR SYSTEM
HOWEVER I HAVE ALSO SEEN HOW MY
PROFESSORS OF STRUGGLE
TECHNICALLY OFTENTIMES NOT
KNOWING IF THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
HAVE CONTINUING POSITIONS.
AND THE NEXT SEMESTER'S TO COME.
AS OF NOW I TO GO STAY OUR
LECTURES MAKE UP A LARGE
MAJORITY OF OUR FACULTY WHO
OFTENTIMES HAVE. TO LOOK
ELSEWHERE FOR MORE ECONOMIC
SUPPORT WITHOUT HOPE FOR TEN
YEAR AS A STUDENT WHO WANTS TO
CONTINUE IN THE CSU SYSTEM UNTIL
I RECEIVE A PHD I WANT TO KNOW
THAT IN THE FUTURE I ALSO HAVE
HOPE.
OF OBTAINING TENURE IN THE CSU
SYSTEM WITH THIS REQUEST OF
THIRTY FIVE MILLION
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED NEW
FACULTY WILL BE ACQUIRED I
STUDENTS INCREASE WE ALSO NEED
TO INCREASE MORE TENURE FACULTY
TO EFFECTIVELY SUPPORT THE STATE
STUDENTS IN YOUR CSU SYSTEM
THANK YOU.
HELLO ANNA GOOD MORNING TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS DON
SANCHES AND ALONGSIDE MY
COLLEAGUES I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION --
I'M A FOURTH YEAR STUDENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
MARITIME ACADEMY -- IN WITHIN MY
FOUR YEARS I'VE SERVED AS BOTH A
FULL TIME AND PART TIME STUDENT
AT AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM -- I'M HERE TO
ECHO SOME POINTS AND FELL ON
ISSUE -- ONE THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FUNDING A 2%
AROUND THE GROWTH WITH THE SIXTY
TWO MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION IN
THIS BUDGET.
WHOEVER WOULD LIKE TO SEE
SPECIFICALLY IS THAT THE GROWTH
BE MEASURED BY HEAD COUNT AND
SET OF FD EITHER AT THE
EQUIVALENTS TO ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDING A SPENT TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO EDUCATION RATHER THAN
INCREASE THE UNITS FIRST IN --
THERE'S A COUPLE SPECIFIC
REASONS WHY WE MAKE THIS REQUEST
THE FIRST BEING THAT LAST YEAR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM TURNED AWAY OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND QUALIFIED STUDENTS --
THE FUNDING WILL ENSURE MORE
QUALIFIED STUDENTS TO GET TO SEE
THE CSU WHEN IT'S MEASURE MY
HEAD COUNT SAID AT THE EASE --
THE GOVERNOR ALSO PROPOSED A
SIXTY TWO MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE FOR ENROLLMENT THESE
FUNDS THE CSU COULD PERRY. FOR
SEVEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AT
THE STUDENTS OR EIGHT THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
STUDENTS BY HEAD COUNT -- AND BY
THE SO MEASURE OF USING ATTY
CALCULATIONS WHICH ARE BASED ON
HOW MANY UNITS STUDENTS TAKE
THIS YES YOU CAN USE OUR OWN
PLANS TO GET CURRENT STUDENTS TO
TAKE MORE CLASSES INSTEAD OF
GIVING STUDENTS WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE BE TURNED AWAY SEE
THAT THE CSU.
WHICH THE CSU IS DOING FOR THIS
CURRENT BUDGET YEAR -- AND
PERSONALLY I THINK.
THERE ARE OTHER MORE APPROPRIATE
WAYS TO FIND -- IN ROOM INCREASE
IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN
INCREASE IN UNITS FOR TUITION --
PARTICULARLY THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE FUNDING AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE CSU
SYSTEM LOOK AT ITS MISSION IN
INCREASING ACCESS FOR
NONTRADITIONAL COLLEGE STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT HAVE
FAMILIES ARE COMING IN A LATER
AGE.
THAT WOULD BE LIKELY TO TAKE
LESS UNITS AND WOULD BE
DISCOUNTED BY USING AN INCREASE
ENROLLMENT BY FTP MEASUREMENTS
THE SET OF HEAD COUNTS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING A LITTLE IN TAY'S I
AM THE CFA IS A POLITICAL ACTION
LEGISLATIVE CHAIR AND PROFESSOR
EMERITA FROM CAL STATE LOS
ANGELES -- I HEAR SUPPORTING THE
GOVERNOR'S ALLOCATION TO THE CSU
BUT PARTICULARLY -- THINKING
ABOUT THE HIRING OF ADDITIONAL
TENURE TRACK FACULTY THE BEST
GRADUATION INITIATIVE IS TO HIRE
MORE TENURE TRACK FACULTY WILL
BE AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THEIR CAREERS IN THE
UNIVERSITY.
THEY WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
MENTORING THEIR STUDENTS THROUGH
THEIR PROGRAM SMOOTHING THE PATH
TO GENERAL TO GRADUATION.
AS WE REPEATEDLY POINTED OUT
USING THE CSU MANAGEMENT'S OWN
DATA THEY HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
POOL OF FULLY QUALIFIED.
OF FACULTY AMONG OUR LECTURERS
THOSE ARE FACULTY WHO ARE ONE
TEMPORARY OF CONTRACTS.
WHO COULD EASILY BE RE
CLASSIFIED AS TENURE TRACK
FACULTY TO HELP ADDRESS THIS
NEED AT SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS TO
THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM WE URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT INCREASED TENURE
TRACK FACULTY FOR THE CSU?
THANK YOU.
CHRIS ARE SUCH AS A CHIRLA THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND ALSO REPRESENTING OUR
YOUTH OUR ORGANIZATION THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM NETWORK VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE COLLEGE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
OUR OUR CONTINUED LEGAL SERVICE
FUNDING.
FOR IMMIGRANT YOUTH AND THAT
COMMUNITIES ON THEIR CAMPUSES AS
WE WAIT FOR THE SUPREME COURT TO
HAVE A RULING ON DOCTOR WE KNOW
THAT THIS.
FUND IS GONNA BE VERY CRITICAL
IN ADDITION THE OUR SECOND
REQUEST WILL BE TO I HAVE A AN
ONGOING NOT FUNDING FOR DREAM
LIAISONS ON CAMPUSES THIS USER
HAS DONE A VERY GREAT JOB IN.
ENSURING THAT A DOCUMENT
ESTHER'S ARE SUPPORTED BY HAVING
MAJORITY OTHER CAMPUSES HAVE
DOES NEED STUFF THAT THEY CAN
TURN TO OUR THERE'S A COUPLE
CAMPUS IS.
STILL NEEDING TO FILL THAT VOID
I AND WE WERE WE CORPORATE
CONTINUE TO REQUEST A SUPPORT AS
THIS IS BEEN AFTER WE'VE BEEN
PUSHING FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GOT
THE LET'S SEE YEAH I'M A YOUTH
ORGANIZER AT CHI Là MORE
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WHY SAID THE
HIGH SCHOOL COMPONENT.
AND I JUST WOULD LIKE TO ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES REQUEST APPLE MORE
SPECIFICALLY I WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST -- FROM YOU TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THE JEAN LIAISON --
BILL AT AYE WHERE WOULD MANY
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS WHOSE
DREAM IS TO GO TO COLLEGE AND A
LOT OF THEM ARE ACTUALLY
THINKING OF GOING TO SEE IS USE.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE THEIR
OWN DOCUMENTED THEY DON'T KNOW
WHERE TO GO.
TO GET HELP EVEN LIGHT TO FILL
OUT A CALIFORNIA DRAMATIC A LOT
OF THEM DON'T HAVE THIS
INFORMATION AND SO HAVING
SOMEBODY ACTUALLY BE ABLE AT BE
TRAINED ON THIS ISSUES.
CAN MEAN WHETHER THEY STAYING
COLLEGE OR THEY DROP OFF SO
AGAIN I REQUEST.
YOU THINK.
GOOD MORNING MY ANYA POLICY
ADVOCATE WHICH ARE LESS WELL
ONCE AGAIN ECHOING MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS AND RESTATE REITERATING
OUR SUPPORT FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THE CAL STATE -- FOR
DOCUMENTS STUDENTS I WAS TO THE
CHARGES OF THE STUDENTS FACE
BOTH INSIDE AND OUTSIDE THE
CLASSROOM WITH FAMILY MEMBERS
AND EDUCATIONAL IMPACT THAT THEY
HAVE.
I'M I'M JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAD TO SEE ISSUES ARE
ADEQUATE PREPARE TO SERVE THEIR
NEEDS ONCE I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JOINT VASQUEZ
HEILIG PROFESSOR OF EDUCATIONAL
LEADERSHIP AND POLICY STUDIES
AND DIRECTOR OF THE DOCTOR NAY
LEADERSHIP AT CAL STATE
SACRAMENTO I'M HERE TODAY TO
TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE.
OF THE CFA IS REQUEST FOR MORE
FUNDING FOR TENURE TRACK FACULTY
AS AN ADMINISTRATIVE LEADER ON
CAMPUS IT'S IMPORTANT TO
PRIORITIZE TENURE TRACK FACULTY
BECAUSE THE CONTINUING
INVESTMENT IN FACT LEADERS
ALLOWS US TO CREATE.
GRADUATES THAT ARE PREPARED TO
LEAD AN EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENTS
THAT PROMOTE LEARNING EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT FOR ALL STUDENTS.
I ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE HAVE A A NOT ONLY A TEACHER
SHORTAGE BUT A LEADER SHORTAGE
IN THE STATE.
AND BY CREATING.
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR TENURE
TRACK FACULTY IN EMPOWERS THE
CSU TO IT RETAIN AND ATTRACT.
TOP FACULTY TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
GOAL THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KATIE
DIXON I'M A POLICY FELLOW WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND ALL OF US ARE
NONE.
THANK YOU ALL AGAIN THIS MORNING
FOR HAVING THIS COMMITTEE I AM
HERE TO SUPPORT PROJECT
REBOUNDING WHATEVER BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS THAT THEY ACT FOR A
WAS IN HERE TO HEAR ALL OF IT --
PROJECT REBEL IS A LOT I'M
FORMALLY INCARCERATED.
PROJECT REBOUND IS A LIFELINE
FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME WE DEPEND ON
PROJECT REBOUND WHAT WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT HIGHER EDUCATION
AND HOW IT HIGHER EDUCATION
SUPPORTS US.
THIS WILL BE A COMMITMENT THIS
WILL SHOW A COMMITMENT FROM THE
STATE TO ALL TO ALL RETURN THIS
TO ALL RETURNING FOLKS LIKE
MYSELF WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA ON PAROLE.
THERE'S NO TELLING HOW MANY OF
THOSE FOLKS COULD ONLY DREAM
ABOUT A HIGHER EDUCATION PROJECT
REBOUND WILL BE ONE OF THE MAIN
AVENUES FOR THOSE FOLKS TO
UTILIZE TO REACH THOSE GOALS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MURATSUCHI MY
NAME IS PRESTON READING I'M A
PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY AT SAN
JOSE STATE AND I LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO.
I'M ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
ON MY CAMPUS.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
SEE A PHASE REQUEST FOR THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN IT IN
ADDITIONAL MONEY TO HIRE MORE
TENURE LINE FACULTY.
AT SAN JOSE LIKE SEVERAL OTHER
CAMPUSES WE ALSO NEED SOME HELP
WITH TRANSPARENCY OVER THIS
BECAUSE THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS ALLOCATED LAST
YEAR.
HAS BEEN OBSCURED IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS ON CAMPUS AND WE'RE NOT
REALLY SURE IFTHE ANY
ADDITIONAL FACULTY HAVE ACTUALLY
BEEN HIRED WITH THAT MONEY --
THERE'S THERE'S NO BETTER WAY TO
HELP OUR FIRST GENERATION
WORKING CLASS STUDENTS THAN THAT
THEY CAN WORK WITH FULL TIME
TENURE LINE FACULTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LONDON
CROWDY I AM A POLICY FELLOW WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PERSONS WITH
CHILDREN ALL OF US ARE NINE AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
PROJECT REBOUNDS BUDGET
ALLOCATION -- AS SOMEONE WHO'S
FORMALLY INCARCERATED JUST
RETURNING HOME. FIVE MONTHS AGO --
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT THERE WERE
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS OUT THERE AND
SOMEONE WHO'S JUST MADE POOR
CHOICES AT A YOUNG WOMAN AND
COMING HOME AT THIS AGE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THERE WERE --
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE THIS OUT HERE
AND NOW HERE IN THE FACTS THAT
WERE.
SENATE TODAY MAKES ME SUPER
EXCITED AND I KNOW PEOPLE WHO
HAVE -- ARE CURRENTLY IN PROJECT
REBOUND AND USING THEIR SERVICES
AND I JUST HOPE THAT I GET
OPPORTUNITY AS WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS RON
MARYLAND ROSTEN I'M THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR PROJECT REBOUND AT
CAL STATE FULLERTON.
I'M ALSO FORMALLY INCARCERATED.
I'M HERE TODAY TO REPRESENT THE
FORTY FIVE STUDENTS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN OUR PROGRAM AT
CAL STATE FULLERTON AND ASK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND URGE YOU.
TO GIVE THE THREE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO PROJECT
REBOUND TO CONTINUE OUR SUPPORT
SERVICES MUSCLE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS.
AND WE STAND IN SUPPORT OF
PROJECT REBOUNDED OR TO TO ALSO
SUPPORT.
I WANT TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MY STORY I STARTED COLLEGE
WHILE I WAS INCARCERATED AT C.
I. W..
AND IT WAS THROUGH HIGHER
EDUCATION WHERE I FOUND A WAY TO
REINVENT MYSELF BUT WHEN I
PAROLED WITH A HANDFUL OF
CREDITS.
AND WAS ACCEPTED INTO COLLEGE I
DIDN'T HAVE A PROGRAM LIKE
PROJECT REBOUND SO WHEN I WENT
TO SCHOOL EVERY DAY I FELT LOST
I FELT LIKE AN IMPOSTOR.
I FELT LIKE I DIDN'T BELONG AND
IT WAS REALLY CHALLENGING EVERY
DAY WHEN I WENT TO CLASS -- MOST
DAYS I THOUGHT SHOULD I DROP OUT
SHOULD I STAY.
IT'S PROGRAMS LIKE PROJECT
REBOUND.
THAT KEEP STUDENTS LIKE ME
COMING TO CLASS EVERY DAY WE
NEED TO BELONG SOMEWHERE
WE NEED TO FEEL LIKE.
WE ARE IN THAT SECOND CHANCE WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN.
GIVE TO OUR FAMILIES TO OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR GRANDCHILDREN
WEEK WHEN WE COME HOME.
INSTEAD OF A PATHWAY TO PRISON
WE NEED TO OFFER THEM A PATHWAY
TO COLLEGE.
SO I REALLY WANT TO URGE YOU.
TO GRANT THE CONTINUED RESOURCE
SISTER PROJECT REBOUND BECAUSE
THIS NOT ONLY CHANGE IN THE LIFE
OF THE FORMALLY INCARCERATED
STUDENT.
IT HELPS OUR CHILDREN AND OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I'M AND WHEN I AM THE FOUNDER
AND DIRECTOR OF SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA.
ABOUT FIFTY YEARS AGO MY FATHER
PROFESSOR JOHN -- WHEN STARTED
PROJECT REBOUND?
AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE.
AND HE DID THAT BECAUSE FOR HIM
DURING HIS FIVE YEAR PRISON
SENTENCE AT SOLEDAD STATE PRISON.
IN THE NINETEEN FIFTIES.
EDUCATION WAS HIS PATH. TO
REDEMPTION.
IT WAS HIS PATH TO REINVENTION.
AND WHEN HE STARTED AND BECAME A
PROFESSOR HE KNEW THAT HE HAD TO
MAKE THAT OPPORTUNITY AVAILABLE
FOR AS MANY PEOPLE COMING OUT OF
PRISON AND JAIL AS POSSIBLE.
AND NOW HERE WE ARE FIFTY YEARS
LATER.
AND IN THIS VERY BUILDING.
YOUR COLLEAGUES ON DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES AND IN ROOMS AND IN
MEETINGS.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE DOWN
THE STREET AT THE CDC ARE ARE
BRAINSTORMING DAY AND NIGHT ON
HOW DO WE BRING THE STATE'S
RECIDIVISM RATE DOWN.
AND YOU ARE PRESENTED WITH A
PROJECT HERE IN THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING ROOM.
THAT HAS A 0% RECIDIVISM RATE.
THAT'S ON HER DEATH.
WITH JUST A SMALL INVESTMENT
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
WE CAN TAKE THIS 0% RECIDIVISM
RATE AND MAKE IT POSSIBLE TO
MORE STUDENTS.
I'VE TALKED TO THE PROJECT
PROJECT REBOUND OFFICERS A
DIFFERENT CAMPUSES AND THEY'RE
GETTING THOUSANDS OF LETTERS
EVERY YEAR FROM MEN AND WOMEN
WHO ARE INCARCERATED AND WANT TO
ENROLL AT C. S. U. WHEN THEY GET
OUT.
THOUSANDS.
LET'S MAKE THIS SUCCESSFUL
OPPORTUNITY POSSIBLE FOR
EVERYONE OF THOSE STUDENTS WHO
IS COMMITTED TO IT.
AND READY FOR IT.
THEY WILL MAKE YOU PROUD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TERRY WILSON AND I'M AN ELEVEN
YEAR EMPLOYEE AT FRESNO STATE
UNIVERSITY IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX THE CSU ADMINISTRATION
BYPASS THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS.
AND UNILATERAL LIMITED SALARY
STEPS FROM SPORTS STAFF OF THE
TWO HUNDRED OF THAT TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE STATE AGENCIES.
THE CSU IS THE ONLY STATE AGENCY
THAT HAS ELIMINATED SALARY STEPS.
AND THE CSU IS THE ONLY STATE
AGENCY DOES NOT PROVIDE SALAR
STEPS TO SUPPORT STAFF.
I HAVE AN UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE
WITH AN EMPHASIS IN MATHEMATICS
SCIENCE AND BIOLOGY I HAVE TWO
MASTERS DEGREES.
DESPITE MY EDUCATIONAL DEGREES
IN CHANGES IN MY JOB
RESPONSIBILITIES AND WORK LOAD
AND CONSISTENTLY RECEIVING
OUTSTANDING EVALUATIONS I HAVE
NOT RECEIVED ANY SALARY.
INCREASES IN THE LAST ELEVEN
YEARS AT FRESNO STATE BASED ON
MERIT.
ADDING FURTHER INSULT NEW
EMPLOYEES ARE BEING HARD IN THE
SAME SALARY.
IN THE SAME JOB CLASSIFICATION
AS ME EARNING A HIGHER SALARY.
THIS YEAR'S HE ALSO PROFITS FROM
THESE ACTIONS.
WHILE EMPLOYEE SALARIES REMAIN
STAGNANT AND THE CSU CLAIMS
PROPERTY.
THIS ISSUE IS INCREASED BY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THE BALANCES
OF ACCOUNTS THAT HOLDS OUTSIDE
OF THE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE STATE
TREASURER.
WITH THESE OUTSIDE ACCOUNTS ALSO
GENERATING TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN INTEREST.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE OVER TEN
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED LONG TERM
CSU SUPPORT STAFF TO SALARIES
ARE INVERTED.
ON AVERAGE NEW HIRES EARN.
SALARIES THAT ARE SEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO DOLLARS MORE A MONTH.
THAN EMPLOYEES IN THE SAME
POSITION ON THE SAME CAMPUS WITH
MULTIPLE YEARS OF SERVICE.
THE CSU EMPLOYEES UNION SEIU
STATE COUNCIL AND TEAMSTERS ARE
REQUESTING THAT ONE HUNDRED
MILLION.
DOLLARS BE ADDED IN ONE TIME
FUNDS THIS YEAR'S YOU BUDGET TO
CORRECT THE SALARY IN VERSION OF
THE CSU SUPPORT STAFF.
IN EXCHANGE FOR THIS ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION THIS YEAR'S YOU
WOULD COVER THE SALAR INVERSION
COST IN FUTURE YEARS WITHOUT ITS
EXISTING BUDGET.
ARE YOU TO HOLD THE CSU
ACCOUNTABLE AND PREVENT ANY
FUTURE FINANCIAL IN JUST THAT'S
THIS LONG TERM STAFF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MATT BROUGHT HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS JUST
THAT TO YOU -- IT TO URGE YOU
ALSO -- TED SUPPORT THE ONE TIME
FUNDING INCREASE FOR CLASSIFIED
STAFF -- OUR MEMBERS WORK IN THE
SKILLED TRADES AT CSCO WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT A HUGE NUMBER OF
MEMBERS BUT THEY SUFFER FROM THE
SAME SORT OF INVERSION ISSUES.
AND WE THINK THIS IS A MATTER OF
FAIRNESS THAT WE LIKE TO SEE
CORRECTIVE THANK YOU.
CAN REALLY RESONATED WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION I HAVE A FEW ITEMS IN
TERMS OF ONE TIME DOLLARS I WANT
TO ECHO THE COLLEGE MY BROTHERS
AND SISTERS THIS YES YOU YOU AND
TEAMSTERS THE CURRENT STRUCTURES
UNFAIR AND UNJUST.
WE HAVE A WORKER THAT'S BEEN
THERE FOR OVER FIFTY THREE YEARS
NESTLING MIDWAY THROUGH THE
MERIT BASED SALARY RANGE I DON'T
KNOW IF HALF THE SENTRIES ENOUGH
TIME FOR SERVICE BUT WE THINK
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE.
BUT THERE'S NO STEPS FOR OUR
WORKERS AND WE THINK IT'S A
MATTER OF EQUITY -- IN TERMS OF
ONGOING DOLLARS THIS YES YOU DID
NOT RECEIVE ANY MENTAL HEALTH
DOLLARS DESPITE ONLY A HANDFUL
OF CAMPUS IS HAVING THE PROPRIA
RATIOS ARE ASKING FOR TWENTY
MILLION ONGOING.
WE THINK THIS OCCURRED BOTH THE
CSU RECEIVED ARE THE UC
RECEIVING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WE ALSO WOULD URGE FUNDING --
FOR IN REAL ENROLLMENT FUNDING
AND HAD CAL AND LOOKING AT FULL
TIME ENROLLMENT -- AND NOT JUST
BODY OR BODIES IN THE CHAIRS NOT
JUST FOR AT T. E. AND THEN ALSO
WE ARE URGING -- TWENTY FIVE
MILLION TOWARDS THIRTY FIVE
MILLION TOWARDS INCREASING
TENURE FACULTY -- WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE STABILITY IN
OUR WORK FORCE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KATHLEEN -- GONNA
ON BEHALF OF COPYING
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER I GAVE
THESE COMMENTS DURING THE
HEARING LAST WEEK ON YOU SEE AND
WANTED TO REITERATE THEM --
DURING THE HEARING TODAY AT
FIRST YES YOU WE WOULD LIKE TO
BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION THE NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
FACULTY FOR BILINGUAL TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS.
ARE YOU SEE CSU IN OUR PRIVATE
YOUR UNIVERSITIES THERE IS A
NEED TO EXPAND EXISTING
BILINGUAL TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS OR ESTABLISH NEW ONES.
IF WE ARE TO BUILD THE CAPACITY
OF BILINGUAL TEACHERS FOR
BILINGUAL PROGRAMS.
INVESTING IN ADDITIONAL FACULTY
WOULD ALLOW GREATER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL STUDENTS
TO BECOME BUT BY LITERATE ARE
BILINGUAL AS PROMISED BY
PROPOSITION FIFTY EIGHT THE
CALIFORNIA MULTI LINGUAL
EDUCATION ACT.
AS WELL AS ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
QUALIFIED BILINGUAL TEACHERS FOR
E. L. STUDENTS.
AB TEN TWELVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RAY HAS INTRODUCED THIS YEAR SIX
SUCH AN INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE SCENE OF FURTHER A PUBLIC
COMMENTS MIDDLE -- WE ARE JOINED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMóN DID
YOU HAVE ANY FINAL COMMENTS NO
NO FINAL COMMENTS JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT I'VE BEEN IN AND OUT OF
MEETINGS BUT WATCHING THIS ON A
CONVERSATION AND I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION FOCUSED ON THE
CAL STATE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITH THAT TO THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED